Guys!
The YouTube... Oh god, what the fuck was that voice crack?
The YouTube servers are down on my side!
Every time I... I can't... I can't even go to my live studio!
Oh wait, no, never mind.
GK, it's okay now.
GK!
GK, it's fixed now.
Okay, I was saying that because I kept getting this!
I was like, what do you mean error try again?
What do you... What do you mean?
What does that mean?
And then I kept like refreshing and everything and then it wouldn't...
Like it wouldn't refresh.
I was so confused.
I was like, why can't I refresh?
I'm so confused.
Painful.
So I'll chat LMG.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Alan.
Alright, so for those who don't know.
For those who don't know...
The store DokiMerch is finally open!
Now there's headers!
Guys!
We have headers now!
Like, we don't really have any new...
Yes, I know, a lot of the items in the store is sold out.
Because we're working on it.
We have two orders until we're able to fulfill the majority of the orders.
Another update.
So yes, Croquis voice pack.
Our very first voice pack is out now.
You can listen to the preview of the Dokimers store of what it sounds like.
I just want you to know Croquis worked very hard in that voice pack.
So yes, check it out.
It's only... it is yours for only $5.
Woo!
I should put $4.99.
Just to entice you guys more.
I was like, oh my god.
For only $4.99 you can get your Croquis voice pack.
Nova, thank you for the gifted membership.
Thank you, thank you.
And Kova, thank you for the five gifted ships.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
So anyway, I am... yes, I am not tired.
Or I mean, I'm a little bit tired.
To be fair, I started my work day at fucking 10 in the morning.
I'm sipping my appy juice right now.
You know, like those like... those like paper... the paper apple juice containers.
Like as if I'm in kindergarten.
This is how I feel like right now mentally.
I'm sipping my little like kindergarten apple juice.
Love that first caw.
And also thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Regarding like... you're like, Doki, when will we have Croquis merch?
I am currently talking with the creators at the moment of Croquis.
Because like, I don't know if people realize this.
I talked about this in the... in the 3D stream.
And it was more so... it was more so of like... Croquis was based off of a free crow model that they made.
And I said that like, oh, I saw it on Twitter.
I saw this free crow model that this creator made.
And I thought it was super cute.
So then I was like, oh, can you do one... design one for me?
That's just like me, like based off of me.
And they're like, yeah, they can.
But because the model is sort of like free for everybody.
Um...
Uh, like the original model is free for everybody to download.
Uh, which in talks at the moment regarding making merch off of Croquis.
Because it is based on her original... her other original model.
So let's... fingers crossed.
Um, like she was open to the idea.
But like obviously we have to like negotiate and stuff about like how to... to do... uh...
To use it like commercially.
So we are currently like negotiating.
Um, to see like... uh...
Um, um, like what we can do.
With regarding Croquis and what we can...
You already missed your oh she...
Bro, Croquis was...
Look, Croquis was made as...
Was like really made as a one-off joke.
I honestly...
I honestly did not expect Croquis to like...
Blow up...
Uh...
Blow up in the way it did.
Like sort of like overnight.
But I'm really glad all of you guys...
Love Croquis.
Who not?
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um...
Croquis is my favorite.
The Dokiverse.
Which is your favorite Doki, guys?
There's so many different flavors of Doki.
Which one's your favorite?
Um...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, anyway.
So yes, I started my day at 10 in the morning.
Um...
Because almost every day I have to attend an interview regarding our new manager slash talent manager position.
Because our staff team, we have hired everybody for our staff team except for manager.
The other staff positions were pretty easy to fill.
Um...
Because we sort of have like a vision of what we want to do.
But a main manager slash talent manager is quite difficult.
Because, uh...
You know, we want somebody that...
Like we want to make sure we don't, you know, fuck up.
We don't...
Because like it's a lot of responsibility.
And it's like there's a lot of work going into...
Going into like the main manager slash talent manager position.
So we gotta find somebody that's perfect.
Because I didn't have to attend any of the interviews.
For the other positions.
Um...
And it was a very like...
Uh...
Well, okay, we didn't really...
We didn't have interviews for the other staff positions.
The manager positions where we do have interviews.
Because this was very important.
For the events and the product management.
It's very like clean cut on like what we wanted.
And like the resumes we received.
And like we...
Like we...
We want...
There was like...
We had like exactly the vision we want.
And because of that it was very easy to hire for...
Um...
The positions.
For those positions.
Um...
But the main manager, talent manager is where it gets a little harder.
Not a little.
Very hard.
Because we don't want to mess up in that area.
Because they have a lot of power.
Uh...
Obviously I'm the main power here.
I want this talent manager to be able to do things.
So that I don't have to be involved in behind the scenes work and stuff.
So I can just say yes or no to things.
Because I'm like the final decision.
Because it's me.
Anyway.
Um...
So like almost every day for the past week or so.
Starting on like you know last Monday.
I think last Sunday.
I've been having to wake up at like 10.30.
Uh...
10.30 a.m.
Um...
Almost.
Or 10 a.m.
Depending on like if I woke up at 10 a.m.
I'll just...
I'll just keep at it.
I'll just be like okay I'll just stay up till the interview.
Because all our interviews are like at 11 a.m.
for me.
And so like I had to like...
You know I have to go and sit on the interviews and stuff.
Just to be like if I like the person or not.
Because they'll have to be like...
Like I don't like you know it'll be awkward to the interview this person.
And then...
And then you know they hire them.
And then I hear them for the first time.
And I get like a weird vibe.
It'll be like...
Ugh I don't know.
Like after they get hired.
So like I have to...
I have to be there for her.
Because I always trust my gut on things.
Like my gut hasn't really failed me so far regarding like who to trust.
Regarding like people to hang out with.
Who I trust.
I always trust my gut.
Like my gut feeling on people.
And so like that's why I have to be there in the interview.
And like I don't talk.
I mute myself.
I just listen in.
I'm like an observer.
And we have somebody that does the interview for us.
And so like every time.
Almost every day since last week.
I have to wake up so early.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to it at all.
And we have a whole month of this to go.
Because we have to do a second interview after the first interview.
After...
Because we're doing the first interview.
And we're cutting the pool in like...
We're cutting the pool in like more than half obviously.
And then we're going to do a second interview.
And then if they pass the second.
Then the second interview is when I actually make my decision.
But we're still in the first step.
We're still in the first interview step at the moment.
And obviously after the interviews.
We have to...
We have to like...
Go through our notes.
Being like what we felt.
Like me and the interviewer.
Be like okay how do we...
How we feel about this.
And everything.
And...
And all that.
Oh my gosh.
Your show is so much work.
So yeah.
That's why I was late.
I was in a staff meeting.
Regarding talking about the interview we just...
Because like it's an hour too.
The interview lasts an hour.
So like after the interview is done.
We have to do notes and stuff.
And then it was like 12.15.
And I was like fuck.
Because we have to release the store.
Because I wanted to.
I had...
You know.
We planned on opening the store before my stream.
So I was like oh my gosh.
Anyway.
The shift our meeting.
Because we have like our other staff members are in the meeting as well.
So like I was like alright time to shift the meeting.
To the store.
And then we were talking about the store.
And then we had to make sure everything is good to go.
We know that one of the Twitch analytics is broken on the store.
But that's not on our end.
That's on the analytics website.
So...
So we had to...
We had to like...
We had to like go and get that ready.
So that's why I was late.
Oh my god.
I have to go to meetings again guys.
But this time I'm the boss.
But yeah.
Anyway.
I saw some of you were like what about Mr. Mel?
I talked about it.
I've talked about it before.
But Mr. Mel is taking a step back.
They are not working on as the main manager anymore.
They're working on like getting contractual work.
So like basically bringing in sponsors.
Bringing in like contracts and stuff.
So we're moving on to like as an agent type deal.
Because agents work on sponsors.
And then they take commissions off of the sponsors that they bring in.
So because of that we are in a transition period at the moment.
So Mr. Mel is working on being more so outside.
Duties.
And Mr. Mel has always been working on this as a side.
Because Mr. Mel has like another job.
Like a main job.
I've always...
I've been like a side gig type deal.
Because Mr. Mel...
If you don't know.
Mr. Mel actually has a main job.
And I was taking it as a side.
To help me get started.
Type deal.
Because you know I fucking started Doki Bird.
Sorry not started Doki Bird.
Returned to Doki Bird.
I returned to Doki Bird.
With basically like zero prep.
Like you know I barely had time to really prep for all of this.
So Mr. Mel helped with getting...
Making sure like you know.
I had like some sort of structure going in.
And now...
Now that like you know.
We've had like...
We're trying to build the structure now.
And Mr. Mel doesn't have a lot of time to really like dedicate fully to this.
So we're looking to...
So that's why he decided it was time to step back.
It was his decision to step back.
And we agreed that like...
He'll be working more so on outside.
Outside rather than...
Instead of like inside...
I won't say inside the company.
I meant more so like in...
Like you know what I mean.
And so he's...
So that's why we're hiring a main...
A main manager.
A main talent manager.
To work on this like full time.
Type deal.
And...
And so because of that.
That's why we've been hiring and stuff.
And...
So we need somebody who can commit more time to...
To Doki Bird.
To me.
And being able to...
Because I also have to do a lot of behind the scenes stuff.
Right now.
And we're trying to avoid that.
Like...
So I can focus more so on streaming.
And I...
All I really want to do is focus more on streaming.
And my creative...
My creative ventures.
Like my projects and stuff like that.
And so we need to hire somebody that's...
Can handle more behind the scenes.
So like...
To the point where I just need to say yes or no to things.
Like I don't really want to...
You know...
I don't really want to do behind the scenes stuff.
I don't really like...
Now I don't want to say I don't like doing behind the scenes stuff.
But like...
I'm...
I'm tired.
I think that's the best way to describe it.
I am tired.
And I just want a stream.
So that's why.
That's my goal.
That's honestly my goal.
Let's see.
Because like every day...
Every day I basically...
Before stream and after stream I just work.
I don't really have time to play video games nowadays.
Like off stream.
The only time I do get to play video games is when I'm streaming.
Because every day I'm always working on something.
Regarding...
Regarding like within the...
We'll just call it the company.
I don't know what else to call it.
Every day I'm like working on something within the company.
And like trying to...
Like I am a workaholic.
But like the workaholic sometimes...
Like as a workaholic...
I take most enjoyment in like working on my channel.
In terms of like stream content.
And like projects.
I don't mean like...
The behind the scenes logistics and stuff.
Is where I...
Don't consider...
The workaholic part.
The workaholic part doesn't really include much about like the paperwork.
And the...
The behind the scenes and the...
And the logistics of everything.
That's not where my workaholic tendency goes into.
But sadly I have to work on these things almost every day.
So...
So when I say I've been very busy.
I've been very busy.
So that's basically where it's at at the moment.
Yay!
Anyway.
What else do I have to give updates on?
Um...
Yeah.
Like I know like we're growing a lot.
To our team is...
Our team is...
This is growing a lot at the moment.
And I don't know if it will be something that we can have forever if I'll have this big of a team.
Forever.
Because I don't know what next year is going to be like.
This year... This year is like... It's been very good to me.
I think as long as now that we have the store out.
I'll say that a lot of the salary has been helped by...
You know, you guys... Of course, you guys are supporting me.
But like... Now that we have our official store out and we got a distributor going in.
We can finally... If we start launching more products more regularly.
That most of the salary...
I think like majority of the salary can be paid off with our merch sales.
Which is great!
I really want to say thank you again, guys.
Like, it's crazy how much merch can... Like...
Like, it's crazy!
Like I said...
If I had regular merch sales...
The merch sales could account for like 60-70% of my salary...
Of like... Of my income type deal.
Like, because merchandising is... Like...
Like, you know how like... Like, Hasbin Hotel...
Pop... What was it?
The Poppy Circus, whatever.
Like, that shit.
Like, merchandising really fucking...
Can make a lot of money for stuff.
And they're... They're right!
It does!
It's actually crazy how much you can actually...
Make out of just merchandising.
And...
But yes, the store doesn't really have anything new.
The only thing new is the KuroKy voice pack.
Plus, I think we only have the Doki Makura...
Only...
We... We really only have...
The Doki Makura stock still in.
Cause...
I think like, apparently I ordered...
Too much of the Doki Makura.
So we have...
We have like...
We have like, sort of like... A little bit of...
An excess of it.
So that's why...
Like, we can ship it right away.
Because we have too much of...
I might have ordered a little bit too much.
So... So those can be...
Instantly shipped out.
So...
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Genuine question.
Are you no longer...
A thief?
Are you considering overhauling the Doki Verse lore given how...
What do you mean?
The Doki Verse is the Doki Verse.
The Multi-verse is the Multi-verse.
Like I said, it is a skin suit.
Like, I can take my skin suit off at any times.
Each skin suit...
So you know how like...
Some people have like multiple passports.
With like multiple identities.
So that's me.
All we know as long as in the inside it's the tomato because like that's my true form So I could be like what do I feel like today?
Do I want to be a thief today?
I also feel like a lot of people forget that I'm a thief here Because I'm not very stealthy
So, you know if I'm on the run I could easily just take off my skin suit and put on a different skin suit So like it's like having multiple passports.
So I have multiple passports like it's not identity fraud if it's my identity Guys, that's not what it means That's not what it means chat, that's not identity theft, it's my identity!
Let's see.
Then, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you after that train simulator stream.
I do not want to flame Doki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also like okay.
It's really funny one of my Friends actually told me about this but like I need you guys like you guys really want lore of the tomato The tomato my true form Was made I was born out of spite
Only the bark knights will remember this
Like the bark knights will remember this moment this stream I never revealed my true form until one stream where it was revealed and created out of pure spite It blew up so much.
I don't remember the full... I honestly don't remember the full thing of how it happened.
Because like, one of my friends brought it up.
Because we were talking about Croaky.
And we were like, oh yeah, I can't believe Croaky became such a big part of you already, like after your release.
And then... and then one of my friends was like, yeah, like, just like your true form, your true tomato form.
That was like a joke slash spite.
And I don't remember, I think it was something regarding like, um...
I think like, I was like, someone talked about how much they fucking hated tomatoes.
And then I started watching tomato videos.
On stream.
And then I was like, that's me!
And then I was just like, oh my god, guys, that's me!
And then I think like, I pissed somebody off.
I don't remember, I like, I pissed someone off.
Because I kept talking about tomatoes and stuff.
And then they got really mad about it.
And then I was just like, that's me!
I'm a tomato!
And then... and then like...
And then like, uh...
A couple months later, I think, and I just revealed it.
I was like, hey guys.
So I had this...
So I've actually been a tomato all this time.
I've had this tomato form lying around for like, a couple of months now.
I just... I just didn't know...
I just didn't know what to do with it.
And then I think I brought it out on the Apex stream.
Was it an Apex?
No!
Yeah!
I brought it out on Apex!
Out of nowhere!
I was just like, hey guys, anyway, here's my real form.
And then...
Yeah,
I just...
And then everybody was like, what the... what the fuck?
Like... like...
It's just like... wait...
You had this... you had this form laying around for like... like a couple of months.
And you just suddenly brought it... yeah.
Just casually just brought it up.
I just didn't know what to do.
Same with the croquis.
I had... I had it for a while.
I just didn't know...
When I could bring it up.
Because it was... I don't know.
I just thought it was a funny idea.
And I... I...
Sometimes I like... I like commission things.
Or like, I order things in advance.
I don't know what to do with it.
I just think it's really funny.
But like, I don't really have an idea.
I don't... I...
It's just that...
I don't have the idea.
I just thought it's funny.
And then like later on, I'll just be like...
Anyway...
Here... here it is.
I'll think of... I'll be like...
Well, I have the reveal.
But like, I don't know how the fuck to... to segue to it.
But at least I have it.
Let's see.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah.
That's how...
Okay, similar to CROQI.
Alright.
Okay, guys.
Before we talk about CROQI more, let me show you guys other stuff, guys.
Look.
We...
I feel like everybody forgot that I also debuted a chibi model.
I...
Everybody sort of forgot about the chibi model that also debuted, guys.
I don't know if you know this.
But we have also had more than just one debut chat.
We have also have other models too.
Such as the chibi model.
So, I'm gonna tell you guys the behind the scenes.
So, the chibi model.
We went through a lot of drafts for it.
Like I told you guys.
We went through like a couple of drafts regarding the chibi model.
So, this is what it originally looked like.
Like the first rough drawing.
Like I said, it's from Preachy.
And we worked with Preachy before.
And it was long.
So, I made some edits to it.
And in the end, it...
Yeah, it was like...
It was pretty long.
I was like, oh, I don't know.
I feel like I have like a fucking...
A six foot tall brain inside this four foot tall chibi.
So...
Long, young man.
And then later on, like this is where the edits got to.
We edited all the way to this.
So, it looks a lot better now.
Now, it's not as long.
Yeah, it looks like I'm Mega Man.
So, in the end, we edited all the way to this.
This was like the rough sketch.
Oh, and then some of you guys might recognize this.
I actually...
I actually gave a sneak peek of the...
Of the...
Chibi model.
A long time ago.
Because some of you guys might remember the screenshot in the member stream.
So...
That was actually came from the chibi model.
Yes.
The screenshot of...
I actually posted a little screenshot.
A crop screenshot of the eye.
And as like a sneak peek in members.
But like...
It was so funny because everybody thought it was the YouTube's figure.
When the YouTube's figure came up.
People were like...
Oh my god.
You were previewing the YouTube's figure in your members.
But jokes on you guys.
It was actually the chibi model.
That was actually the preview I posted in the members channel.
Give me this Mega Man blush.
Thank you for the super chat Gamma.
Thank you.
So yes.
It was...
That was the original...
That was the first preview I gave.
That people were like...
Huh.
And we had actually had like different styles going in.
We were like playing around with different eyes.
So this was the original concept.
What the eyes originally looked like.
I will show you guys.
This is actually what the original...
The original eyes looked like.
I was not...
Sorry.
Wait.
You're just gonna see my hat poking up above.
I wasn't really feeling the eyes in particular.
Because I felt like...
It just felt a little bit off.
So like I asked...
So we were going through like...
So many different like...
Eye designs.
Because like...
I'm a huge perfectionist.
When it comes to these things.
So we were going through like...
A lot of like...
Like...
Being like...
Oh...
I want to fix the eyes.
Like this is the only issue...
That I had there.
So we were like going through different eyes and stuff.
So this is another...
Eye concept we had.
Where we removed the bottom of it.
And then we had...
This version.
Where it's like...
Black pupils and everything.
And then...
I didn't really...
I was like...
What do I look like with black pupils?
And I was like...
Oh god.
I look like I'm staring into your fucking soul.
So...
So I was like...
Oh...
Maybe...
Maybe not.
Because I look like...
I'm staring into your fucking soul right now.
With those black eyes.
So then we were like...
Okay.
Why don't we do like...
Something like this.
Not the black eyes.
But...
Um...
Like...
With the pupils being a dark green.
And...
I don't know.
I don't know...
And then...
We finally settled with...
Uh...
We finally...
After all of that...
We settled with...
What we have here.
So...
This was...
Uh...
This is what we settled with.
Because I thought...
It would look...
The best.
But then it wasn't over.
I was like...
No.
We gotta remove the bottom part.
The bottom part doesn't look that great.
And...
And so, in the end... Boom!
That was the eye style we went with.
You see all these?
It's just small little changes can affect a model so much.
Because I felt like, you know, you can see from this, it really changed how...
Oh wait, sorry.
It really changed how it looked in general.
From the little eyeliner in the bottom can turn into something...
You know, just change how it looked in general.
So that's... Like I said, I'm a huge perfectionist when it comes to this.
I'm a huge stickler for details.
And, you know, I want something that...
Looks like, you know, appealing.
So...
This is where we ended off on.
And it gives off such a different vibe.
It makes it a lot cuter.
So it went from...
So original all the way to the end.
Let me show you the original again.
It's crazy how far the design process was for this.
It was a lot back and forth.
I really appreciate Preachy for like...
For willing to, you know...
What's the word?
For willing to like...
Go through with the back and forth and the attention to detail and everything.
So it went from...
Let me save this real fast.
Sorry, my English today is extra fucked up.
My brain is like still booting up at the moment.
So my brain today is extra slow.
So this is the original.
Oh my gosh.
From the original which was super long.
To...
To this.
So...
Yeah.
A lot changed.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
A lot definitely changed.
To get to where we're at.
From big brain to...
To something that truly reflects my bird brain.
Yeah.
It's actually crazy.
While I was working on the new...
While I was working on the new skin suit.
While I was like talking to...
Our...
You know...
What's the word?
So we have a skin suit designer.
And then what would you call somebody that makes a skin suit move?
Like...
You know...
I don't know.
I guess like the skin suit tech.
Okay.
And then the skin suit tech guy.
The skin...
The puppeteer.
The skin suit...
The skin suit engineer.
Yes.
The engineer.
So I was talking to the skin suit engineer.
So that they are...
They can help build the skin suit up.
So the tomato form can easily go into it.
So the skin suit engineer.
I was talking to her.
And I was like...
Being...
Giving me like critiques and stuff.
Being like...
Yeah, we should swap this.
And then she was like...
Wow!
Like I didn't even notice that.
You have like...
Like really close...
Like...
Like good...
Like eye on things.
When it comes to attention to detail.
And stuff like that.
So like...
I...
I'm a huge perfectionist.
Like I said.
So...
I really want things to look good.
So that was the before and after to how...
How we got there.
Oh yeah!
You should see like...
My edit.
Like I would like actually edit the...
Like the work in progress that were sent to me.
So like...
This is like what I sent...
I'll show you guys what like I sent back to her.
For the 3D.
So this is like what I sent back to her.
I was like...
Oh!
I don't know.
It feels like...
Too long.
So...
And then I would send this back to her too.
I would send this back to Preachy.
On like how I think...
Because I thought the arms were too long.
As well.
So I edited the arms.
And I made like the body...
Like a little bit shorter.
Because I thought the body was too long too.
So I like squished up various parts.
And proportionate and everything.
And...
So it was like more so of...
A back and forth to get to where we're at.
And then I think I did like another back and forth too.
So then after they edit it...
I would be like...
Okay.
I want to edit again.
And then we would do another edit.
And then where it gets closer and closer to like the original...
To like what we have today.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyone else not buying into this?
Obviously she has a pit in the basement where she keeps her victim.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know what you're talking about, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So...
Yeah.
It was a lot of like back and forth and stuff.
And finally, the plushy design was actually...
So easy.
Because we sort of like...
Had a...
Since we already have the...
You know, we had like the model done.
The plushy design was very like intuitive on what we really wanted.
And...
I'll show you guys.
So at first, we just went like...
We were thinking like, oh, just smile.
But then I was like, no, open mouth.
I really wanted to be open mouth.
So then we went from this to this.
And I was like, no teeth.
We need teeth.
Because I don't want to be like mushy baby mouth.
You know, we're like...
It's weird.
There's no teeth there.
It's just weird.
So then we added teeth.
Because I don't know.
I just thought it was weird that it was like fucking...
Like some fucking...
Baby with no teeth, you know?
So we went from this to this.
And that was like basically how...
What the final form looks like in the end.
And it was very easy.
It was just like small changes.
It was just the mouth and everything.
In the end, it looked like this.
In the end, we had this.
So yeah.
Like I said, I don't like having really long delays when it comes to merch.
Because the one biggest issues I have with that...
Like in the future, there will be pre-orders.
But I'm going to try and minimize the pre-order dates.
Because the worst part about like pre-ordering stuff as a consumer is the very long wait.
And then like, you know, people move.
A lot of people move.
And it's also a huge...
It's like a huge deal to handle on the distributor side.
Because they have to like handle on where people are going to be moving.
And changing the addresses.
And some people canceling orders and stuff like that.
Or like they forget they ordered something like this.
And then or like it's just too much.
So I won't...
And then, you know, manufacturing delays happen.
Like right now, I have the Lunar New Year stuff.
There is a manufacturer delay with the Lunar New Year stuff.
Because we had a little error in production.
And because of that, I'm not planning on opening pre-orders for this until the majority of the process is done.
And more so.
And then like we can put pre-orders for it later.
We can order like, you know, we have like a set amount ordered.
And then we'll pre-order.
And if there's extra, if there's excess, then we'll have...
We'll order more at another time.
But yeah.
So it's a bitch.
And it's actually like such a bitch to deal with when it comes to like changing of addresses and everything.
And also...
Well, not like a bitch to deal with.
But like more so like it's a lot of work to deal with.
Because when there's a pre-order going in.
And we...
Because like, you know, one or two person changing of address.
Very easy to handle.
Like you just make a note of it in the order sheet.
But when we have a lot of people, like, you know.
Like, you know, people have lives.
I don't know if you know this.
But I think you guys are not bots.
And there's actually like real people watching me.
And you real people have lives outside of me.
So...
So I assume you guys will have, you know, you guys will have to move.
Or you guys will be doing other stuff, you know.
So I know like somebody would say like...
Oh, but we're YouTuber fans.
So we know how long it takes sometimes.
Guys, please respect yourself more.
Like, it's like...
Okay, so it's more so of like I want people to be...
Like I don't want that to be like a norm.
You know?
Like I don't want that to be like a norm for my store.
Because...
Like somebody's like I have merch I waited over a year for.
Yeah, but I feel like...
I feel like that shouldn't be like the norm in things.
Like I understand for...
For things like figures and stuff like that.
Like that I understand.
Because figures, obviously.
They take like...
They...
Like manufacturing cost for figures.
It's a lot.
And you know, they're hand painted and everything.
But I feel like small things like this.
Because I've waited...
I've waited a year plus for figures and stuff.
Which I understand.
Because figures is like much more...
There's more like manufacturing into it.
And...
And stuff like that.
So I understand.
Because a lot of them are like hand painted.
And everything.
So to deal with the order process.
But I feel like smaller things like this.
I'm willing...
I don't want to have like long pre-order times.
Because they are like...
Smaller.
And like...
And...
And you know...
I don't want you guys to have buyer regret.
After like half a year.
Of waiting.
Like you waited half a year.
And you're just like...
Why did I order this?
It's like...
I don't want you to have buyer's regret.
So I'd rather have like...
Shorter pre-order time.
Or like in a way.
Or like...
I don't...
Or in a way where like...
You...
You don't have to wait too long.
To receive your product.
But because we're still...
You know...
Like right now.
That's why I'm not opening new orders for stuff.
Because I want to make sure.
Um...
I want to make sure that...
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
By Sonya...
Easier to make.
Like I understand like figures taking a really fucking long time.
And stuff like that.
But I feel like...
These things.
Like you know...
Like acrylic stands.
Fucking plushies.
Okay.
Plushies does take a lot.
But it's also...
Plushies taking a lot.
Is also due to the fact of...
The process of making it into a real product.
Like a real full-sized product and stuff.
So...
Um...
And...
And I want to make sure that...
You know...
It is...
Like...
This looks...
This is gonna look like what I see.
Like...
This can look good in a 3D for...
Like shit like that.
Like I want to be sure that I will be able to actually produce this before I make you guys...
I don't want you guys to pre-order a PNG.
And then...
So...
So you know like...
And it looks like a fucking bootleg.
You know like those like...
Like okay you know like those like nendoroid plushies?
Where um...
There's like a bootleg version of the nendoroid plushie.
And then you look at the...
You look like...
Oh that like the PNG of it.
And then like yeah the PNG pre-order.
And then when it goes into like the actual plushie.
It...
It looks like...
It's like...
And then you bought like a bootleg version and stuff.
And it's just not what you think it looks like.
Okay let's see.
Bootleg nendoroid plushie.
Oh my gosh the knock-off shit is...
Oh no like...
Oh I think the best exam...
Okay yeah like...
Wait that's so good.
This is such a good example.
Wait I need to show you guys.
Okay.
Wait this is actually such a funny example.
Alright I don't want it...
I don't want it to...
Oh my god what the fuck?
I'm just...
I've been looking at the knock-off.
So...
So like this is...
I don't want my plushie to look like the one on the right guys.
I don't want it...
I want my plushie to look like the same quality as the last.
I don't want it to look like the one on the right.
Oh my god wait I can...
I'll show you guys.
Okay so like...
So my friends are making plushies and stuff.
Wait.
Oh it's so funny.
Wait I need to...
I need to show you guys.
Okay.
So my friend...
Two of my friends actually they recommend me the plushie manufacturer and it's so funny.
Oh my god.
Okay wait I need to show you guys the...
It's so good.
As in like it's so bad.
So my friend is making...
Wait I need to...
Wait actually does she like...
Also if I say...
I suddenly...
If my stream suddenly stops working I need you guys to know it's because the power's out.
I forgot there's like power maintenance and stuff so if my power...
Oh it's the internet.
It's one or the other.
It's either internet or power.
I can't remember.
I think it's internet.
So like if I suddenly stopped streaming the internet cut off.
So...
I posted...
So that's why I just disappeared.
Yeah I heard that the chat is really weird though.
I'm gonna see...
Actually I don't know if I should show it yet because I don't know if she like ever announced these plushies so I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure that I'm not accidentally leaking anything.
Because I remember asking like oh yeah can I show and she's like yeah like but I don't remember if she ever...
Like showed these plushies yet to you guys like for like pre-order and stuff.
I don't...
I don't remember so I'm making sure I don't accidentally leak this out.
Don't leak.
I know I'm making sure I'm researching.
I'm researching right now.
Wait let's see if my other friend's online first.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Shit okay.
Oh.
I'll ask her.
Okay.
I'm messaging.
I'm trying to remember not to read the message out loud.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh.
Alright.
We won't show it until we get approval because I don't remember.
I don't remember.
That's the issue.
I actually...
Okay.
I don't think I seen her tweet about it before.
Wait has she?
God damn it.
I don't know guys.
I don't know if she ever tweeted it out.
I'm not leaking deep night.
I'm a good person.
Alright I'm checking her Twitter right now to see if it's gonna leak or not.
To see if she ever posted pictures of it.
If she didn't post pictures of it, I'll wait until I get a reply back.
But it's so... oh my god, I wish I...
It's so fucking funny.
Like, that's all I can say.
Because like, you go from prototype to the finalized version...
I just want to send that...
To that one guy that's still waiting for Sandland.
We're gonna get there!
We'll get there soon!
You had four other Sandland parts, let me...
Don't worry, we'll get there soon.
All the people here now waiting for Sandland.
We'll get there soon!
I couldn't make the behind the scenes its own thing, guys.
There was just... there was like too many things...
Okay, I don't have enough content to make it its own stream chat.
So we had to... we had to do it here.
Okay?
We had... Sandland needed...
Sandland had like four other streams.
It's okay with sharing its...
It's okay with sharing a bit of its stream time with...
Oh, I got approval!
Okay, guys.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
It's so funny.
So they're making like...
So, Morikawa plushies.
And...
And they were sending me...
Because like, I asked them for like advice on plushie manufacturing.
And this was like...
This was the first prototype that they received.
So this one's from Poki.
Poki Pokums.
And it...
Oh my god, it's so fucking funny.
Yeah!
Every time!
This is the...
I'm sorry.
This is the very first...
Um...
Prototype.
That was like...
Sent to her.
And I was like, why is it...
Why does it have like a fucking trash bag?
Because they're trying to get the pattern...
The...
A pattern down.
So...
So like...
She was like...
So this is like the illustration.
This was the illustration.
And this was...
Um...
This was the...
First prototype.
This is what I mean!
It's very hard to prototype plushies!
So...
So this was like...
The very...
The illustration they sent.
And then they received that.
So then, you know...
My friend was like...
Um... No.
So they had to do like edits and stuff.
So like, you know...
They had to do edits and be like...
Yeah, can we like... you know...
Fix all of that.
And then...
Fix the...
Um...
The drafting of everything.
So they're just waiting on the second...
I don't think I was sent the second prototype.
Because they were, you know...
Yeah, now it looks like clothing.
But it went from...
Potato sack to...
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
It's so funny.
It's so...
The potato sack is so funny.
It's actually...
Oh my god, it's so good.
I love looking at it.
Anyway...
My friend...
Gigi, she is a big Xenoblade fan.
So this was their...
It's not as like big as a transition as it was.
The Kali one.
Because like...
So this was like the first prototype.
And then...
This is what it looks like afterwards.
Which was a huge improvement.
I am...
But...
This was the second...
The final.
So the transition between these two...
Worked...
Like more seamlessly...
Than...
You know...
Than the Kali one.
To be fair, the left one is naked too.
So it looks scarier.
Because it's like...
When things are naked, you are just like...
Why is it naked?
You know?
Like...
Oh...
Yeah...
So...
So yeah...
I mean the left one is naked.
But then...
So now the right one has clothes.
So it looks less threatening.
Uh...
What the...
So...
It's less...
Yeah, the right one looks more friendly now.
The left one is like...
Yeah, I'm naked.
What are you gonna do about it?
Uh...
Yeah, so...
So that's...
That's what I mean when I meant like...
My...
When I say like plushy prototyping is...
Very difficult work.
Um...
Because... you know...
From the first prototype to the end...
And majority of the pre-production...
Majority of like...
Oh sorry, you're right.
We need like...
Naked bars on it.
Give me a sec.
Alright, is this making you guys uncomfortable?
I know a way...
To solve this.
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Let me...
Let me see if I can do this.
Alright, uh...
And then opacity is...
Oh wait, no.
It is...
Background opacity.
There we go.
So we can cover their identity.
Alright, so like I said...
The one on the left is a...
Criminal.
So much better.
Is that better guys?
Will we ever get a tomato plushy?
Yes!
In the future one day.
One day you'll get a tomato plushy.
Um...
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh... When are you doing the Sandland...
Donation... Donatathon?
Where you play Sandland for two months straight?
We're already at like one month of Sandland.
I did not expect Sandland to go this...
Uh... To go this far.
Uh... So...
I mean we're nearing two months to be fair.
We're nearing two months...
For... For Sandland.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One more month to go guys.
One more month.
Yes!
Check out GG and Poki.
I love them.
They're really great friends.
And they were the ones that suggested the...
The plushy manufacturer to me.
So...
When I get the prototype...
Prototype one...
Don't worry guys.
I'll...
I'll make sure to show you guys...
What it could have been.
You know...
I'll make sure to show you guys...
What the plushy could have...
What you could have got...
If we had a shorter production.
Um...
But yes.
Anyway what else?
Oh yes!
Croaky!
Uh... Croaky.
Alright.
Let me grab...
Let me grab the croaky stuff.
Real quick.
Uh...
I didn't prep any of this.
To be fair.
I just went straight into it.
Alright.
Let me grab the stuff real quick.
Oh my god.
There's so many messages.
Guys.
Okay.
I did not realize I have...
Alright.
I need to reply to some emails after this stream.
I did not see this.
Um...
Alright.
I'm going to reply to this.
And...
No.
It's not my business email.
It's my other email that I use to contact people for commissions and stuff.
So I separate those two.
I separate like my...
Because I'm contacting people for commissions myself.
Personally.
So I separate my business email with that.
I didn't realize...
When I woke up.
I didn't realize that...
Um...
That I had emails.
I replied in a day.
I feel like CROQI...
CROQI was sort of really...
Easy in terms of like...
To get finalized.
I did ask for like variations on stuff.
Because I really want to see what it looks like.
So...
CROQI could have like...
I wanted to see if CROQI...
Was just...
Was just like one full flat color.
So like there was no like...
Extra...
Uh... things to it.
Let me see if I can... I think it's this one.
No that's the naked guy.
Here we go.
So CROQI could have looked like this.
Where it was just...
Uh...
The wings was...
It's not it's own color.
But I felt like it blended in too much with the rest of the body.
So I was like...
No.
So let me see.
And then...
Yeah and then after that I was like...
No I want CROQI to...
To have you know...
To have like...
You know the wings being like...
I think like CROQI originally also...
The body was...
Darker as well and I didn't like that too.
So...
We changed so that...
And so we changed it to having the wings darker.
And...
Oh my gosh where is the first CROQI?
Where the fuck did the first CROQI go?
Oh yeah wait.
Okay there it is.
So yeah CROQI could have looked like...
Where is the other one?
Uh...
No that is not...
CROQI could have looked like extra dark.
And I was like oh yeah no.
Cause the...
The color balancing...
Like you could barely see...
My expression and everything.
So like I was like oh my gosh...
It's a little bit...
It's like CROQI is...
It was too night mode.
The...
The hat just did not translate...
Very well.
With the darker version...
Of CROQI.
This is like what is it called?
Like the evil-er?
Evil-er CROQI.
So yeah CROQI...
CROQI also went through...
A lot...
Not a lot but a few minor changes.
In emo CROQI.
You know it's like shadow CROQI.
Oh my god CROQI is Sonic.
And this is shadow CROQI.
Hahahaha.
Um...
Yeah the worst...
Worst timeline CROQI.
Um...
I didn't like the color changes of the beak as well.
I felt like the beak being the same color as the body.
Felt like...
Uh...
It represented the best...
Out of all of them.
But yes there is...
This is shadow CROQI.
If we give shadow CROQI a gun it would be perfect.
Uh... CROQI...
CROQI the crow.
Shadow CROQI and CROQI.
We just need to give shadow CROQI a gun.
And then everything will be perfect.
Ah not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
CROQI.
Hahahaha.
Um...
But yes that was basically the CROQI process.
Now!
New skin suit.
Alright.
I said I'll give like...
I'm honestly... I talked about it in the community post.
But yes I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
I'm scared.
I've been like...
I've been like anxious about the...
The new skin suit.
For like a couple of months now.
It is a gamble.
It is a big gamble.
Because like you guys know.
My current skin suit.
It is four years old.
Like um...
It can now walk and talk.
I mean...
Yeah.
Hahahaha.
It can... you know.
It can go to kindergarten now.
And like this is the skin suit that everybody like...
Knows me by like now.
And like it's...
You know everybody sees this and they're like...
That's DOKI!
Yeah.
That's me.
But I... like it's still like...
A past of me.
As well.
And if I had a choice...
Um...
To like you know...
Come back with a newer skin suit.
I would have done it.
But I couldn't.
Because one day...
One day is not enough.
When it comes to prepping a...
New skin suit.
So that's why...
I was... I'm really scared.
Hahaha.
Because like I said a lot of you guys are very used to what I look like now.
And...
Um...
But I felt like I...
Changed a lot.
As a person.
As a tomato.
I changed a lot and grew a lot as a content creator.
And...
I felt like I really wanted to...
Um...
Have something that...
Basically merges all my experience together.
And also...
Feels more like...
Me.
And...
The thing is...
Being a thief is all about stealth.
Well...
Hahaha.
I think we know by now that I'm not a very stealthy person.
So I could be the worst thief imaginable.
Hahaha.
I've been...
Technically the worst thief imaginable when it comes to stealth.
Mendy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki with a revolver and in the old west.
And has her birthday on July 4th.
And still trying to fight the being American allegations.
Thank you for the super chat Mendy.
Thank you.
I bet you guys didn't even know Shroud's Canadian.
Hahaha.
You guys just assume...
Everybody's American.
I bet you guys didn't even know Shroud's fucking Canadian.
Hahaha.
He could have been the most American person there.
But you guys didn't know.
He's actually Canadian.
Oh my god.
Did you know the actor who plays Homelander...
I saw the actor who plays Homelander.
I knew he had like an accent.
But I always thought he was British.
But then I found out the actor of Homelander was...
Is actually New Zealand.
I was like oh my god.
Well I know Tenz is Canadian.
I knew that.
Because like...
I used to watch Tenz...
A long time ago.
So I knew that he was Canadian.
He's Canadian.
I actually found out...
Shroud's Canadian.
From like...
My short that talked about Shroud.
And somebody commented...
Oh he's also Canadian.
I was like what the fuck.
He's 30 and he's Canadian.
Oh my god.
But yeah.
Anthony Starr the guy who plays...
Homelander in the Boys.
He's actually from New Zealand.
He's a fucking Kiwi.
I didn't know that.
I thought he was British.
I thought he was like...
A lot of people who play American characters...
Usually they come from...
I mean to be fair.
Usually they come from like...
The UK.
When they try to do like American stuff.
Like you know the guy who plays House.
God what's his name.
They have really good American accents though.
They have really good American accents.
It's actually crazy how good their American accents are.
Cass thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry Doki.
Our evolution going to bird mode didn't hurt too much either.
You'll be fine.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fox thank you for the super chat.
Just by the silhouette it really brings back memories.
I know it's gonna be so you.
Try not to worry Doki.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Fox thank you.
Thank you.
Nethy thank you for the super chat.
Honestly I don't mind the first facial expression.
Because it looks as if you're judging us.
Also sad life.
Guys we're gonna get to sad life soon.
I know I said that like 30 minutes ago.
But we're almost there.
Okay.
We're almost to the sad life.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay Doki.
Asula is also a cowboy cosplayer.
And he's not American either.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No matter if it's a new skinsuit.
We will still adore you Doki.
Of who you are.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
We're not even in Sandland anymore.
We're in fucking forest land.
We're not even near Sand.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
Regarding the new skinsuit.
Like I said.
I am wearing.
Obviously it is a big change.
Some of you guys were giving examples.
But they do that too.
But they still kept main characteristics.
Of like.
I guess like.
They kept main.
Key main characteristics.
From each suit.
To make them.
So that the transition is easier.
The new skinsuit.
There might be a big change.
When it comes to certain parts.
It's also like I said.
It is a new skinsuit.
Creator.
So um.
Clea is not the.
Clea has had input as well.
Regarding.
Design concepts.
And stuff.
So like she had input.
Regarding it too.
She helped with some of the parts.
Trying to figure out what I wanted.
For her and my new creator.
Both worked together.
When it came to figuring out.
The new skinsuit.
We went through a lot of concepts.
We went through a lot of drafts.
To like pinpoint exactly.
Like okay.
I'm satisfied with this.
But I am worried.
I am scared.
Because like I said.
It is a big change.
And uh.
And like it definitely will not.
Look like this.
When it comes to like.
The style and everything.
It's a new brand.
And obviously.
It is a gamble.
It is a big gamble.
Because changing brands.
Doesn't work all the time.
Hahahaha.
So.
I'm scared.
Hahahaha.
Change is very scary.
We all are scared.
Of change.
So I really do hope.
You do end up growing to like it.
If you are like weirded out.
By the new look.
That you will still grow to like it.
Because no matter what.
In the inside.
It's still a tomato.
So like.
It just has a new skinsuit.
A different profession.
Hahahaha.
So.
That's all I hope for.
Hahahaha.
So yeah.
That's really all I really want to say.
About the new skinsuit.
Um.
I worked really hard with.
Preparing for it.
The team that's preparing.
The stuff for.
For.
Saturday.
So like.
Um.
I hope you guys will enjoy.
What I'm cooking on Saturday.
Hahahaha.
You know when I say like.
Um.
This project is going to be my biggest one yet.
I think.
This project.
Well.
I won't say like down or like the Vichat worlds did take a lot of fucking work.
Uh.
When it came to like the team itself.
And um.
The team handling itself.
And me looking in.
But I feel like since this.
This is the most people I've ever hired.
When it came to working on a project.
I think that's the best thing I can say.
Regarding on what Saturday is going to be.
Saturday might be like.
The most people I've ever fucking hired.
To work on it.
Hahahaha.
So.
I hope you guys will enjoy Saturday.
I really do.
Also.
Um.
Because of that.
Because of how close my new skin suit reveal.
Is.
When it comes to my birthday.
We're gonna.
You're gonna realize that Saturday.
Might as well be sort of like.
Similar to what a birthday project might be.
And because it was so close to each other.
The birthday might not be.
As cool.
Hahaha.
On Saturday.
We might.
I'm gonna let you guys know.
I'm treating.
I'm treating Saturday as.
My birthday project.
So.
Hahahaha.
So like.
Because of that.
My birthday will basically.
Pretty lackluster.
When it comes to.
The Saturday.
Because I couldn't do two big projects in a row.
Hahahaha.
Um.
Yeah.
Skin day over birthday.
Hahaha.
So I hope that's okay.
Because I know like people were like.
Oh she's gonna plan so much on this day.
Oh my god.
And then her birthday's gonna be like.
Two weeks.
Oh my god.
That means her birthday is gonna be.
Also amazing.
I just want to please lower your expectations on the birthday.
Hahaha.
Because I spent all my effort.
Daring people for.
For skin suit day.
Hahaha.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As long as it feels like you're on the inside.
That's what's more important.
You'll still be a little tomato no matter what.
As long as I am still your little tomato.
That's all I care about.
That's all I want.
Alright.
Finally.
After an hour and fifteen minutes.
It's Sandland time.
Okay wait.
JK.
Because I need to boot up Sandland.
Give me a.
Hahaha.
Guys give me a sec.
Just gotta boot.
Oh wait.
Gotta plug in my controller too.
Give me a sec.
I plug in my controller.
Alright.
And then.
Oh no.
My cables are tangled up.
So I gotta untangle my cables.
Give me a sec guys.
I'm untangling my cables.
And then.
And then it's Sandland time.
Then it's gameplay time.
The 10% of you guys here.
That's for Sandland.
Hahaha.
That's it.
Oh my.
Hahaha.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I think my favorite part of all this.
Is the moment I was like.
Yeah.
It's Sandland time.
I like.
Fifty people left instantly.
Hahaha.
Okay.
That's it.
Not gonna lie.
That's really funny.
Like not gonna lie.
That's.
That was pretty funny.
I'm.
That they're weak.
Don't keep their fucking wings.
Scattered.
Let's go guys.
The people that actually cared about Sandland.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need a.
They don't understand.
Exactly.
Peak gameplay.
Now some people are like.
Well I wasn't even gonna stay for Sandland.
But now that you called me out.
I'm gonna stay here.
Out of spite.
To prove you wrong.
Um.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They hate trees.
And they hate sand too.
Alright.
Let's see.
They aren't properly addicted to the Tokium.
Thank you for the super chat Coyote.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where's my solo.
Alright.
Then we gotta swap.
To uh.
Where's Sandland.
There you go.
Sandland.
Yay.
Alright.
We're in forest land now.
For those of you.
Who are watching Sandland for the first time.
We're in forest land.
Yes it was click bait.
We're actually in the forest right now.
Your comrades are living it up.
You're not joining them Ann?
Ann and.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sandland filters out the weak dragoons from the insane.
What?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Do we not have normal dragoons?
Yeah.
Do you intend to keep that from them forever?
No.
I'll tell them.
Oh she's not gonna tell them she's half demon.
Why not get it over with now?
Sometimes you gotta wait for the right time prince.
Tell them you're half demon.
The more it'll eat away at you.
If you're going to tell them.
Better sooner than later.
Maybe you have a point.
They might as well know now.
They might be racist against demons.
But like.
But you're half a demon.
And you're like one of the three women in the camp.
Alright.
It'll be a bit awkward though.
They end up burning her for a witch.
Everyone listen up.
Half demon no wonder she is so hot.
I'm calling you out D-Dragon.
Burn her!
She's a witch!
Or she's half a demon!
Burn her!
Huh?
Is this some kind of joke?
I'm being serious.
I had no idea either until recently.
Wouldn't their mom look different?
Like.
Wouldn't the mom look like a fucking demon?
There's no demon there that looks human.
Long ago.
Cause they'll be like.
Why are your ears pointy?
Jp thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The weak shall fear the sad.
It's true.
Can't believe it.
Queen Lilith was a fiend all along?
Heatherlyn thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your very first super chat too.
I knew.
We have real Sandland Dragoons here.
I knew it.
I thought Fred was the one who was lying to us.
Turns out the only liar was you.
Oh no.
Long ago.
But like a fiend protected them.
A fiend saved their lives.
This is a serious matter.
It could threaten the very existence of the resistance.
I apologize.
Wouldn't a fiend teaming up with them.
Already threaten the resistance.
It wasn't my place to share a secret.
King Jam and Queen Lilith wanted kept so badly.
Like we already teamed up with literally the prince of the demons.
Oh, she's a succubus.
Whoa!
Damn, that must be wild.
That must have been wild for King Jam.
Jam is a real one!
Finally,
the forest satin line.
Nerdy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Man,
that's some straight up prejudice there.
Maybe we should revisit this tomorrow morning.
We have another similar conversation?
What does this change?
She's just half fiend.
Like that changes nothing.
Anne, I'm so sorry for causing you such distress.
Oh, I'll survive.
It was just a bit of a shock.
Now I've kind of warmed up to the idea of being part fiend.
Finding out I've got an uncle was a plus too.
Okay, but like... okay.
Okay, but like...
okay.
I'm just so confused.
Is that... like she could always talk to animals or bugs.
Like, did she not tell anybody that?
And be like, hey, that bug just said hi to us.
Like, did everyone just thought she was crazy?
Aren't you bothered by your allies turning...
There's like one thing I don't really...
Like, there's always like such big potholes when it comes to like...
Anime in general.
Oh, it comes from any story, not just anime.
One of the biggest potholes that I've been like thinking about a lot...
Was the fact that like...
For those who ever watched Dr. Stone...
So like, you know how they started off in the village?
That village is full of inbreeding from six people.
It started off with six people and that village grew to 50 villagers.
I kept thinking about it.
I was like, did they inbred to this?
Like...
Because the village started with six!
And then it grew to 50 people!
And I've been thinking about it the past week, guys.
I've been thinking about...
I literally was thinking about it the past week.
And like, I was like googling it.
Because I...
Yeah, let's sleep.
I was just like, how did this happen?
And I was like googling it.
I was like, is it inbreeding?
And everybody on Google was just like, yeah, most likely.
And I'm like, why did they not explain this?
I was just like, why didn't they explain this?
I didn't know!
I didn't know it was like, they actually came from six people!
Yay!
They don't though!
Their only health issue is...
What was it?
Pneumonia?
They have like pneumonia and fucking...
Some little child who needs glasses.
That's the only defects they have.
We'll vote, we keep on resisting too.
There's no one.
Oh shit!
This guy is extra racist.
Oh nevermind.
Nevermind.
He's not.
I'll be the bigger man.
How about you, Bien?
False alarm.
He's not.
What are you talking about?
So they're not racist!
They're just sheep!
They believe whatever the fuck they wanna believe.
They believe whatever the fuck the main person believes.
They're all sheep!
They don't think for themselves.
Before then, they were super racist against demons.
But now that they're okay- now that this guy's okay with it, they're like, you know what?
I just like being in a group.
I- They're like, I just like being in a group right now.
I don't wanna leave.
I wanna be included.
They don't have ideals!
They just follow whatever the main person believes in.
The Aquanium!
The Aquarium!
Wow!
You actually know where it all is?
Now we have the tracker!
This story would've been more interesting if there was one guy that left and joined the enemy team.
...transported at high speed.
There's still one left that Brad hasn't gotten his hands on yet.
Alright, which one is it?
It's a battleship.
A sunken ship, known for giving even famous junkers trouble.
But then if we had that happen, this game would be like 50 hours long instead of 30.
That's no reason not to go.
Indeed.
We leave as soon as everyone's ready.
Well, we're traveling light.
So we might as well go on ahead.
Yay!
Oh, we finished the quest.
We never finish it.
Oh my god!
She's finally in my party!
It only took like 4 parts!
Holy shit, you're finally useful!
Just because we replaced you?
Oh my god!
You finally matter in my game!
She's real!
Oh my god, this took fucking forever!
Holy shit!
It took us fucking forever to make her matter in this game!
Oh shit, okay.
Can I actually jump off?
No, okay, thank god.
Oh my god, she's relevant again.
She could have helped me like 80 years ago, but that's okay.
Alright, ancient gold coin.
Ugh, I don't need treasure maps.
...any rare items you find.
Alright.
I'll make it worth your while.
Not sure if it's true, but I remember hearing that some groups of people evolved the genetic traits that reduced the effects of inbreeding.
Clock, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
There were six people!
It doesn't matter if it reduces the traits of inbreeding!
It was six people that started the village!
And that's assuming they made two kids per couple!
...
Alright.
Let's see.
Can I bring out...
Okay, I can't call the ride yet.
That's why I was so confused!
Like, I didn't think about it!
And then I was reading up Doctor Stone lore, and then they were talking about how there's only one village in the entirety of Japan, and for that lore.
So I was just like, ok
So I got so... I don't know.
I don't know.
One of the biggest issues with Dr. Stone is that Dr. Stone is all about science and scientific discovery.
But if it's about science, then why the fuck do we have an inbreeding problem?
Why is there... why are they not solving the issue?
It's about science!
The entire...
Oh, goodbye.
The entire present... premise is science.
So like what... Oh my god, I keep going.
It's not... It is!
How can there be a village of 50 people and the biggest issue they have is that somebody needs glasses?
Like they don't have any like...
Like...
They don't have like, you know, like the Egyptian problem.
With the Egyptian royalty and how, you know, what was it?
King Tut has so many health issues.
And that wasn't even 3,000 years!
That was like, at best, 600... 500 years!
King Tut had a fucked up back.
Um...
Like, elongated head or some shit.
And like, uh...
And like, bad jaw.
And she had so many health issues.
But like, the best...
The worst that happened to that fucking...
The village of 50 was that one girl needed fucking glasses.
It doesn't make sense!
Hahahaha!
Like, if it was any other...
Any other manga or like anime, I'm like...
That's fine.
Like, have that plot hole.
But it's literally about science!
And the science...
It's literally about science!
So, that's like the biggest scientific issue I have!
And at least the Pharaoh's Inferno wasn't as bad as like a fucking...
Village of Six?
Anyway, that's all I really want to talk about.
Like, that's...
This is my issues with, uh...
This is my issues with like...
Anime plot holes.
Not just anime plot holes, but like...
Like, plot holes in general.
It was worse.
The science is simply not being affected by genetic inbreeding.
Uh...
You're thinking too much.
No!
Because Dr. Stone is all about thinking too much!
Because it's about science!
They literally went so in deep about engineering...
And like, uh...
Chemistry and all that shit.
But not...
On how to make glass.
And how to make medicine.
And like, um...
How shit... like naval... naval...
Ships work.
But what about...
GENETICS!
It's more about noticing patterns.
Adjusting intentions.
That's all.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done now.
Well, goodbye.
I'm not okay.
Oh, whoops!
Guys, it didn't work, guys.
No, you have to go all the way back!
Oh, I didn't.
Oh, thank God.
Never punished!
I love not being punished!
Okay.
Alright.
How do I get on this?
Yes.
Uh...
Ruz, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
As someone who took two courses on evolution genetics, the inbreeding issue is primarily misunderstood by a...
Name it as an absolute.
Sick people can produce a population of offspring conditionally.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, explain.
You can't just say it and just be like, trust me.
I took two courses.
Two courses.
I don't think explains enough.
Source me.
Wait, it's the Omega Raptor.
It's not as good as the Alpha Raptor.
Write a thesis now and argue for it.
Okay.
Also, like, I don't think two courses can explain why the fuck six people can make sure inbreeding is not an issue.
Citation is needed.
Who is your pre-review source right now?
Get your professor on the line and explain to me the science of Dr. Stone inbreeding.
That's all I want.
Nice!
One down!
I have 100 words with references now.
Make sure, make sure it has like citations.
I want MLA format.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Explain.
Sounds like a lot of science.
I think we need an inbreeding art for Dr. Stone.
The thing is, Dr. Stone is a science.
What kind of an inbreeding art is this?
Dr. Stone is a science!
They ended Dr. Stone.
They ended it, and I felt like I didn't get my answers.
Here we go.
Make sure not to go in so deep that you can't touch the bottom prints.
Wait, what?
Uh-huh.
Thanks.
What?
What does that even mean?
What does that mean, thief?
Dr. Stone.
They did have a prequel!
That's the thing!
They made a prequel about the astronaut thing!
But it didn't answer anything!
It just implied that the village started off with six!
Alright,
this way we go.
Alright.
How far is this place that we have to go?
I mean, to be fair, it is a big map.
Pretty far, huh?
It is a...
We need somebody to do a case study right now.
You know how like YouTubers would like recreate...
Okay, okay.
I stopped talking.
We don't need that.
Okay, but you know how like...
Okay, you know how YouTubers...
Oh my god, there's cows!
I knew they were an invasive species too!
There's no way cows would survive!
There's no way cows could survive in the sand!
I knew it!
I knew they came from here!
Okay, so you know how like YouTubers will like recreate certain things in anime?
Like the Attack on Titan gear and stuff like that?
And they'll be like, oh this happened in the anime.
Can it actually happen in IRL?
So this is Forestlands capital.
It's impressively vast.
You bet this place will keep us entertained for a while.
Yeah, the city does have a lot to offer.
This is a nice city.
Oh, it's the capital!
Wait, oh my god!
It's him!
It's his twin brother!
I think they ran out of models.
Wait, it's him too!
It's not a matter of whether you can or not.
Wait, are they all the same people?
Wait, what the fuck?
Are they part of my crew or are they actually the same people?
There's no way!
Did I just found the twin?
Oh my god, what if they actually had another version of these guys?
Oh my god, it's him again!
Hello!
This is also him!
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do we have to...
Oh, where do I have to go?
Wait, did I went the wrong way?
I'm not sure.
Oh.
Oh, I was not supposed to...
Oh, and... whoops!
I was not supposed to go there.
Oh my god, it's so far.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna fast travel to the entrance.
Uh...
It's way too far.
I'm gonna fast travel to the entrance to get out of there.
I don't wanna walk!
I'm too lazy.
It's all the way over there?
Oh my god, it's so far!
It's so fucking far!
Alright, here we go.
I think it's just cause like...
Wait, what?
Where...
Where is this?
Where the fuck is that?
Wait, how do I get there?
Oh my god, I am so lost.
I'm so lost.
Oh, there's a road!
I fucked up with the road!
Hey, if we fall, we'll just deal with it!
Oh, there's a road!
Okay.
Are you crazy?
Here we go.
Oh yeah, no.
Okay, spoiler alert for those who are actually keeping up today.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Uh, for those who actually wanna keep up today with Dr. Stone.
Look, I didn't really read the manga.
I only watched a bit of bits of the anime and I'm like, I read the whole lore and story of Dr. Stone.
I just didn't read the manga itself.
But I read everything about it.
About the chapters and the arc.
So like, for those who are keeping up with Dr. Stone and don't wanna get me spoiled.
Mew for like 30 seconds and I'll give you the reason why people turn into stone.
Okay.
Mew yourself now.
Alright.
The reason why people turn into stone is because aliens.
There you go.
Alright, now I...
After all of that, it was because of aliens.
I'm just like, after all of that, it was that all along.
Just...
It's always...
IT'S ALWAYS ALIENS!
I...
I feel like...
I feel like whenever they're like, what do we do?
And then they're like, aliens.
That's like their answer to everything.
Okay, how do we know to unmute?
Okay, tell them to...
Tell them that they can unmute now.
Now they can unmute.
Also, uh...
Sumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just had to talk about that.
Like...
Like, I understand if it's like, you know, you're like, ooh, you're supposed to have your brain up...
Holy shit!
How far is this place?
How far is it?
And the army uses them too.
So like...
Um...
I realize a lot of like...
Anime and manga that I thought was like, really smart back then...
If...
But like...
But when you like, reread it...
Okay, I love Death Note.
Don't get me wrong.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, there's snakes!
They were snakes.
Alright, I'll let you guys...
I'll let the children live.
I'll let you guys live.
So you guys can be stronger than me.
And then your mother.
And then I want you to do a revenge arc.
And show me how strong you become.
Anyway...
So like, I love Death Note.
Don't get me wrong.
Death Note's a great anime and manga.
And I love the series a lot.
I love the author.
But like...
When you reread it...
You're like...
Wait, this is actually...
For like, the fucking smartest...
For someone who thinks he's like, so fucking smart...
I think it was all the premise about being like, oh my god, he's so...
I am...
I am light.
I am the smartest man in Japan.
But he's like a fucking high schooler.
He's like...
He's like a goddamn high schooler.
And he's like...
I am the smartest person in Japan.
And he's rubber.
He's 17.
He's like...
I'm going to be a god!
And he's a fucking 17 year old child!
I was obsessed with Light.
I remember back then, I was like, oh my god, Light is so smart.
And now I'm like, oh my god, this fucking child.
Oh, it's him!
Why are you here?
Do I even need to ask?
Oh yeah, bro wanted to be normal, so he pulled out an 18 plus magazine.
Oh yeah!
Yeah, doubt it.
Oh, come on.
Did we really have to do this?
I'm not in the mood to throw fists with you chumps.
Good.
Then take your men and leave.
See, that won't work either.
I got a job to do.
You just can't make some people happy.
Yeah.
Yeah, fight us!
Fight us!
No tanks!
Final destination!
How about whoever reaches the engine room first gets the aquarium?
Well, I have a bike.
So, you want to race?
Oh no, no way.
I'm really bad with races.
I suppose I'm better than you.
What?
I suppose this is the best we could hope for.
Unless it's Garfield Kart.
I'm really good at Garfield Kart.
Wait, by foot?
But I have a bike!
Wait for the signal.
On your marks, get set, go.
Wait, but if he says it...
But if he says it, that's cheating.
On your marks.
He's gonna go before...
Before go.
What the fuck?
Huh?
It's dark.
There's no sun in here.
Awww, he's cheating.
Put your goggles down.
It's a cool factory.
Oh my god, cheater.
Bring out the bike, it's too late.
He already cheated.
Get the bike.
He already cheated and it's good if I can get the bike now!
Okay.
It doesn't matter!
He cheated first, it's bike time!
Wait, how is he so fast?!
He was on foot the entire time!
That's not fair!
How is he so fast?!
It's not.
Guys, I think he did more than just use flashbang, guys!
I think he cheated even more!
Who would have thought the bad guy cheating even more!
Alright, we don't need crocodiles here.
They're invasive species.
They came from flatland.
He cheated already.
What?!
Bro, he flashbanged me and you want him to join us?!
What's wrong with you, Adan?!
Not everybody's a good guy!
Alright.
I know he's hot, but like... come on, Elvis is dead.
Wait, how do we... how do we get this?
Wait, do I... wait, how do I move this?
Can I pick it up?
Oh, I can back grab it!
Yeah!
Okay.
Alright.
Grab!
Alright, and then what?
And now push it?
Push!
No!
Which way do I push?!
Firmly grasp it!
Now move.
But yeah.
Yeah, like... oh yeah, this is why!
And then I also had an issue with Riz, thank you the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Light being smart went out the window when he self-doxed himself by murking someone on a talk show only broadcasted in Japan.
Oh god I'm good.
Yeah, cause like, when you...
When you first read the manga, you're thinking like, Light is so smart, but the older you get, you realize he was a stupid fucking child.
Like, with a huge ass ego.
And then...
And now I'm like, oh my god.
Oh my god, I've encountered these people before in content creation.
People who are too young with too much power.
It makes sense.
I was like, holy shit, everything makes sense now.
Yeah, it's the point, I know.
It's like, oh my god.
That's the whole point.
But when you're younger, you're like...
When you're younger, you look up to light.
You're like, oh my god, he's so smart and cool.
When I was younger, reading that, I was like, oh my god, light is so smart and cool.
But as I got older, I was like, oh my god, he is a stupid ass child.
Someone please, he has so many issues.
Somebody slap this guy.
He needs to be slapped right now.
Yes, I unironically got it.
I did.
I thought he was so cool.
I unironically like light as a character.
I mean, I thought L was interesting too.
I thought he was interesting.
But I thought they were both really cool characters.
L is also a huge... Okay, confession.
Yeah, you know.
Confession time.
Okay, we need to... oh, you gotta hold it?
Okay.
No, no, I don't need to go on.
People who... people already get the context.
Yeah, I... yeah.
I used to... yeah.
Yeah.
I was not 18, by the way.
Just so you guys know.
I was definitely underage.
I just need... I want to be transparent with all of you.
Okay.
Whoa!
No backseeks, Toki.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
No, I...
Yeah, I... I figured, you know.
Since he was older and he was clearly smarter...
Yeah, he was... he was... you know.
He took the top bunk bed.
No name, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
There you go.
Yeah!
Wait, where do I have to go?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
Oh, I need to find the box.
Where's the other box?
Where the fuck is the box?
Is that the box?
Where's the box?
How am I supposed to... oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
It's like there's so many boxes, but where is like... where is the real box?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my god.
It's like there's so many boxes, but where is like...
where is the real box?
Oh, and I also was a huge Nier fan.
I loved Nier so much.
I used to really enjoy the character Nier.
I heard the anime ruined him.
Okay, guys.
I only watched the first season of the Death Note anime.
I didn't watch the second season because everybody kept saying the second season was really not good.
So I watched clips of it, but I never watched the second season because everybody said they ruined N.
Sorry.
N as in Nier.
Yeah.
Yeah, everybody said that the second season butchered N and I actually liked the character.
Sorry, I called him by his real name.
Yeah, I actually really enjoyed that character in the manga.
But I heard the second season of the anime really butchered him.
So I was just like...
I docked... Oh no!
What did I do?
Write him in the Death Note?
Oh no!
No!
But yeah.
I thought he was a cool kid.
I thought he was just misunderstood.
Okay, he was anti-social as fuck.
I mean, you would be too if you lived your entire life in the fucking basement.
In L's basement and like all you had was the orphanage.
Uh...
To be fair, L was...
What the fuck is this?
It's just all red crates.
Where is the loot?
Where the fuck is my loot?
Wait a minute.
Where is my loot in this... in this world?
Where is it?
Hello?
Loot?
What the fuck?
Is this a maze?
They gave me a maze in a dungeon?
This is bullshit.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they put me through a maze.
Where is the yellow paint?
Exactly!
This loot better be fucking worth it, guys.
This loot better be goddamn worth it.
Okay.
Woop.
Where is it?
Alright, there you are.
Get over here.
Guys, I think I might be a little under level.
Just... just a little bit.
I think.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, that like might be like overdoing it too.
Just a little bit though.
I don't know.
Only a teensy weensy under level.
There's more?
Oh, okay.
This better be the sickest loot ever.
Okay, how do I jump again?
Uh...
How do I...
Okay.
How do I do the...
Oh, X!
Thank you.
Thank you, game.
Oh, there was loot right here!
No!
Bring me back up!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Thank god there was loot right here.
Okay, this better be some sick ass loot, guys.
I feel like I've been here for a while.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, there's more.
Machine gun scrap?
I need a machine...
Whoa!
What are you doing here?
Get out!
Okay.
Tank time.
I definitely need to upgrade my tank.
My tank definitely needs it.
I feel like if I did more of the side quests, maybe...
Maybe my tank would not be as...
Would not be as scrappy as it is now.
Nah.
Nah, that can't be it, right?
Wait, where am I?
Where am I now?
Where am I?
Do I go here?
Like, actually, where am I?
I'm so confused.
Like, where have I gone?
Did I...
Am I going...
Oh, wait.
Is this where I'm supposed to be going?
What?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I end up going the right...
Oh, it like looped back.
Oh.
It looped back.
Wait, that's crazy.
Thank God.
I was like...
I was going to be like so lost because I didn't know where to actually go.
Okay.
Okay, we're going to beat up some bombs real fast.
There we go.
Whoa.
Okay, this guy is so strong though.
He's so fucking strong, which I appreciate.
Okay.
Okay, we're going to have to...
No!
I want to open it!
Okay.
Let's see.
We're going to jump up.
Yay!
And then we're going to jump like a normal person.
I'm going to get off the machine.
And then...
No!
I'm too slow!
I don't jump high enough!
Wait, I got this.
Here we go.
Okay.
What if I cheese this a little?
Okay, nice.
Alright, we don't need anything.
Yay!
For cheesing!
Hey, if it works, it works.
I don't need a jump bot.
I have legs!
Okay, this way.
This way.
Up I go.
Yeah!
Oh, okay.
That should be a boss fight.
Alright, I'm going to use the bathroom real quick before we go into a boss fight.
I'll be right back, guys.
First bathroom break today.
I'm back, guys.
I just remembered this was supposed to be a race.
Okay, that's...
That's actually a little awkward.
Technically, we're racing.
Okay.
All right.
Where are they?
Where are these fuckers?
Oh my God, they're being like pussies!
Get down from here!
That's right.
That's what you get for not staying down.
Okay, we definitely need to upgrade the puncher, though.
The puncher guy actually does so much damage.
Get them towards...
Slow and steady, everybody.
Slow and steady.
Now just keep going.
Carry this.
Lift, throw.
Oh, there's a throw.
Volume throw mode.
Oh, okay.
It just tells me how to throw.
Okay, lift.
And then, boom!
There we go.
Guys, don't worry.
This power...
Guys, I know this is a battery and like...
I should be gentle with it, but it's okay.
It's made of titanium.
Like a robot chucking 200 meters at it?
No, it will be fine.
At 200 miles per second?
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay.
Where is the... Oh, it's over here.
Okay, I'll just push it.
It's like, where's the other one?
Alright.
Yeah, it's made of aquarium where apparently you can chuck it now.
Nice.
What a great puzzle.
Wait, water?
Okay, I'm gonna punch you.
Get over here.
Daddy's not done with you.
There we go.
Nice.
Happy father... Happy belated father's day.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, where's this guy?
Yeah!
Wait, there's more?
What did I say?
Get out.
Alright.
I'm gonna get rid of you too.
Robo smash!
Alright.
Is that it?
What else do we have to kill?
What else do we have to... Oh, it's open.
Okay, nice.
That was easy.
Yay!
Damn, that egg has hands.
I like how it's like...
Cause like... Oh shit, that's a fucking wall.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec, little guy!
No!
I'm not tall enough!
Okay.
Let's get rid of him.
And get rid of him.
And then we gotta... I need a loot!
Yoki needs loot!
Oh wait, I need to be a big guy to grab that battery pack.
Okay, nice.
Uh...
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong button.
Alright.
Get over here.
And then...
Oh!
Oh my god.
I think it's so stupid that he chucks the battery that hard.
Cause like, you assume you have to be gentle.
Look at it!
It has like, electricity warning.
You assume you have to be like...
Super gentle.
Where's the other battery though?
Where would the other battery go?
Yeah, it's a looting time.
Where's the other one?
Oh, there it is.
God, they're all just boxes.
This should be yellow.
This box should be yellow 100%.
Get over here.
Kobe!
Yeah!
They're built different.
Alright, here we go.
Uh...
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
No!
I'm too big!
My...
My Iggy needs to lose weight!
You're beautiful, Iggy!
Don't let them say that about you!
Alright.
Let's see.
This way.
Wait, do I have to...
Oh no, that's just a crocodile.
Okay.
Get over here.
I have double misses.
Okay, where do I go?
Oh, this way.
Wait, then why is there...
Why...
Why is there like...
Oh!
Who's this?
Okay, I was gonna say...
Like, why did it make me go there?
I'm so confused.
Yay!
Dark energy!
Alright, and then...
Wait, there's a door there!
Does that mean loot?
When there's a door, does that mean loot?
Okay.
No!
You're also too big!
That's not gonna stop me from getting my loot!
Wait, my fucking bike died.
That's awkward.
How the fuck did my bike die?
How do I get across from there?
Oh, I need to go from the other side.
Wait, unless...
Guys, I know it's a race, guys.
But like, I...
I...
Loot is more important, chat.
It is a race, but then like...
Does a race give me loot?
I don't think so.
It just says you win.
That's not loot.
Okay, we have to go here.
We go to the other side.
Loot is always more important.
Yeah, you might win like...
Uh...
Yeah, you might get a trophy.
But that's not monetary.
That's not a game.
Goodbye.
It was worth it.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Oh, it's 2D time.
Is there any enemies in 2D time?
No, okay, there is.
Don't worry, he'll explode before he gets to me.
Timed it perfectly.
Alright, up we go.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit!
Never mind.
Uh...
Wait, there's another entrance here.
That means there's loot.
No, it's just a dead end.
Oh my god!
It baited me!
It knows all I want is loot!
Okay, this way.
I assume there's like nothing on the other side, right?
Oh!
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh no.
It saw...
Guys, it was strat.
I died so I can be on the other side.
See?
It was a strat.
They couldn't chase me because I was on the other side.
You're so smart, Doki.
Guys, where's my...
Puss.
Where is it?
Where is my echo chamber?
You're so...
Oh, Alex!
Oh, you didn't have to say that out of your own free will.
Oh my god, that's so sweet, Alex.
Guys, why can't you be more like Alex?
Okay.
Whoa.
Upper punch.
Oh, I love it.
It's aimbot.
Wait, the punches are aimbot.
Oh, I love it.
I love it.
That's great.
Oh my god.
Guys, be more like...
Out of your own free will too, chat?
You guys shouldn't have.
Isn't that great?
You see, this is why we become streamers.
Wait, whoops.
Am I okay?
Oh, no, I'm not.
No!
I have to redo this.
Okay, no, I don't.
Wait, I have to redo this?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
This is not fair.
I literally have to redo this entire portion?
It's fucked up.
It's this way.
Oh, oh, thief drowned.
Okay.
I'm gonna go back to the stream.
All right, we're fine.
Nice.
All right, and then we grab this again.
It's okay.
We're fine.
See, everything is fine.
I can redo this portion.
I ain't scared.
How much HP do you have?
Okay, not enough, but that's okay.
I won't repeat it again.
Nice.
Double hit.
All right.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
All right.
Nice.
All right, where's the big boy?
Big boy, get over here.
I'm gonna punch you.
No, big boy!
Who said you can run away?
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, that's not good.
What if I just...
Oh, okay.
Uh, guys, I did not buy anything.
Okay.
Uh, whoa.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
That's not a lot of damage, but like, we'll take what we can get.
Okay.
We will take what we can get.
Oh, guys, I might have fucking did not repair anything.
Where are we back?
Oh, we're back.
Nice.
I didn't even realize my internet died.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even realize that.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna reload my chat too.
Are we all good?
Okay, here we go.
Are we back?
Oh, nice.
We're back.
Okay, nice.
See, nothing bad happened.
Guys, the entrance is still here.
Yes, we know.
Take it to the floor above.
Okay.
I think that was on YouTube.
YouTube's been like experiencing some weird shit lately.
It took me like chat was...
I think YouTube servers are like extra fucked.
I'm pretty sure YouTube servers are like really bad at the moment.
Yeah, yeah.
That one is a YouTube issue.
I know for sure.
Because like when I started this stream, I had like really weird like I couldn't start my...
I couldn't start my stream at first.
Wait, there's like loot there.
How do I get there?
I just jump here.
Oh shit!
Okay, wait.
I think like...
Is this 2D time?
Oh, it is.
That's so weird.
Wait, where would 2D get me?
Woo!
It's gotta get to me first, loser!
Wait, it just took me by surprise.
I'm back here.
And what's the point of this?
What the fuck was the point?
I don't understand.
Wait, what was the point of the line?
What?
I couldn't...
Okay, this is like one of those like game design question mark.
I'm literally like game design?
Game design?
YouTube is getting more scuffed lately.
I feel like it's just like server issues.
Because the thing about like YouTube servers is that they can't really delete videos.
So like I'm pretty sure like there's like people out there that are...
Oh, that is not good.
People out there that are intentionally uploading as much content as possible just to fuck with like YouTube servers.
Because like you can't delete content off of YouTube servers.
It's all about like...
They all just...
All they can do is just always expand.
Yeah, all they can do is just keep on expanding and keep on buying more servers to account for like YouTube videos and stuff.
So I feel like it's like...
It sucks because like they can't really do anything about it in regards to like the people wasting.
Like...
They're wasting YouTube space.
So like I won't be surprised if that's also an issue.
Yeah, all those four hour videos are adding up.
All those like...
No, all those videos that like when people search up like, oh, I want to watch this movie but on YouTube.
And it's just like eight hours of like a PNG being like, please visit our website if you want to access...
If you want to watch this movie illegally and shit like that.
But like in the end, it's a scam.
It's just malware.
That shit pisses me off.
Wouldn't they be able...
Yeah, but how would they know?
They don't know if it's actually dead accounts or like...
Because they don't have like...
I don't think they legally they can do that.
I'm pretty sure.
And you're just like...
Bro, I thought they'll have like, you know, one out of...
Remember when people used to upload part one out of 20 for like random shows or TV shows?
Oh, no, I'm about to die.
All right.
This way.
Guys, who said...
Oh, okay.
Who said I can't parkour?
It's not like I almost died or anything.
I'm pretty sure you can't delete videos off of accounts.
Because like you can't...
You don't really know if they're actually dead accounts or not.
What if somebody just randomly logs back in and their account's gone?
That's it.
Then people will get mad.
Because you don't know what the situation is.
Like, what if like, you know, they were stuck in a cult for like 20 years.
They could be stuck in a cult for like 20 years.
They could be stuck in a cult for 20 years.
Okay, nice.
I drank water.
Stay hydrated.
And like they just...
And then like they just got back into access.
And they finally left the cult.
And then they're like, man, I can't wait to access my YouTube account that I used to own before I joined the cult.
And then it's gone.
They deleted it.
You don't know that.
Well, they're like the one thing that was going to...
That like put like, you know, after going through 20 years of being in the cult.
The one thing that was keeping me going was my YouTube account that I still own.
And I can't wait to get back to it.
Oh, man.
That was the one thing every day.
I just think about my YouTube account and I cannot wait to one day.
Be able to get back on.
And now that I left the cult.
That would suck.
That would suck for them.
Wait, how do I?
Okay.
See, wait, there's like no way to...
No way.
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck is the thing?
God, my thing is about to fucking explode.
It's like, it's like one hit.
A fly is going to land on it.
I'm going to die.
Man.
Yeah, so they can't do anything about it.
Whoa.
Okay, we're going to have to grab the hover car.
We're going to bring the hover car into this.
Wait, the hover car does more damage.
What the fuck?
I should have been the hover car this entire time.
We don't talk about the fucking little bullets.
Nice.
Oh, wait, there has to be more loot behind me.
Wait, there's more?
What do you mean there's more?
That's not fine.
He can't aim.
That's the best part.
Oh, wait, I can't do anything now.
I just have to stand there.
All right.
Nice.
He's dead.
Give me the materials I need to upgrade.
No.
Nice.
All right.
That means there could be loot over here.
Because there's a door here and that's yellow.
It's yellow.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, y'all.
Just got back from watching a movie at my brother's place.
How's everyone doing?
We're doing great.
We're making progress, I think.
Is there loot?
Yellow!
I love yellow.
But where do I go after that?
What do I do after here?
Okay.
How do I?
Oh, is it bike time?
It's bike time, right?
That should be.
Okay.
I gotta...
It's bike time.
I just need to get the position correct.
All right.
Bike time!
Woo!
Oh, nice.
Wait, that was so cool.
That was like some Akira shit right there.
And then is there more loot back here?
There has to be.
There's bins here.
Getting all this loot, but Doki doesn't even upgrade.
Doki, what's the point?
You don't even upgrade.
That's the principle of things, okay?
All right.
I have to go here.
You watch Akira?
No, I just know about the slide.
Everybody knows.
Okay.
Like, I understand.
It's like the reference of all time.
But it's like, I feel like animation companies always do that reference.
It's always that reference.
There's like so many Akira moments, but it's always the motorcycle slide.
Because it's cool.
It's like the reference to make.
It's like to let everybody know that you...
I feel like it's like the...
Okay.
It's to let everybody know that you watch anime.
Like, you know, for like Western.
Western shows.
It's like the calling card to be like, yeah, I watch anime.
Inserts Akira slide.
It's very cool.
You wouldn't get it, Doki.
I just think it's funny.
It's always...
That's like...
That's like always the Easter egg to let everybody know that you're an anime watcher.
Let's see.
Is the ad...
Yes, it is like the...
It's like...
It's like the calling card.
It's like how would these people know that I also watch anime?
Yeah, it's like...
It's the anime reference.
It's literally the reference to let everybody know.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Why did it just gently put it down?
Okay, there we go.
Oh my God.
Is an anime mainstream now?
You think it is, but it's not.
Normies do not watch anime still.
But we have...
We're getting more...
We're infiltrating.
Like I say, where would I barely watch anime as well?
I mean, I'm out here watching Young Sheldon.
I'm part of the norm.
I'm part of the problem.
Oh my God.
I think there's like this...
Apparently, there's this...
There's like...
I don't know if he's like famous or anything.
But there's like this football...
NFL football player that was like...
I love Pokemon.
Like he did like...
He was at like a Pokemon convention or something.
And he's like, why are you...
And then he was in an interview and he was like, why?
And then the interview was like, why are you here?
And he's just like, I like Pokemon.
I love his response.
And he's like some NFL player or some shit.
I think they're neat.
Is it Jamel Williams?
And then he...
Apparently, NFL has these like introductions and shit.
And he made like a Naruto intro.
Wait, I need to show you guys.
Wait, okay.
This is like very off topic.
But I have to show you guys.
It's so fucking funny.
Let me upgrade this first.
Let me get stronger.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
It's so fucking...
It's like such a...
It's like such a funny video.
Sean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, you're supposed to keep dormies out of my...
Is his name Jamel Williams?
Okay, Naruto.
Is it that one?
Oh, here we go.
Here, here.
It reminds me of the Jordan Peele skin.
Oh, wait.
My Chrome was on.
But it's so funny.
That shit is so funny.
I was like, what is he doing here?
Bro, and then he was at like...
Like I said, he was at like some fucking Pokemon convention.
Because an enumerator found him and was like, what are you doing here?
And he's like, I like Pokemon.
It's always crazy to see.
And then there was like this famous singer.
I don't know who it...
I don't keep up with like pop culture stuff these days.
But there's apparently a famous normie singer.
Like a singer that normies love.
That like loves anime and shit.
And she like...
During one of her concerts, she showed everybody her JJK plushie.
I was just like, what?
She like just pulled up a JJK plushie and was like, look at this.
Was it Megan Thee Stallion?
I don't remember.
I just thought it was so funny.
I thought it...
I thought it was so funny that she like pulled...
Like she brought her...
Brought the plushie to the stage.
And was like, look at this.
Was it Megan Thee Stallion?
Wait, I need to get to this video.
I saw it on Twitter.
I thought it was so fucking funny.
Like in the middle of her set, she just pulls up JJK.
I was like, what the fuck?
Alright, we got to get rid of these guys.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Please.
This is supposed to be a race.
How did he get there so fast?
There's security in here.
How did he not trigger security?
And all the security is on me.
I can't understand.
There's clearly security here.
Why am I the one that has to deal security?
He was in front of me!
He was literally in front of me!
He has stuff.
This is why I'm going to become a bounty hunter.
This is fucking why.
Who cares about stuff when you're a bounty hunter?
You just pew pew pew pew.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I have to go?
Where's the door?
Oh there's the door.
Okay let me pull up.
I need to pull up that video now.
I need to...
I don't know if it is her.
Megan Stallion, JJK plushie.
Was it her?
Wait, does it even like...
Does it even show up?
Does it even...
Okay, plushie concert.
What's this?
Megan Stallion live.
Oh wait, I think it is!
When does she bring up the plushie?
When does she...
Guys!
Guys, where do I find the plushie scene?
Okay.
I can't find it.
I give up.
That is like my extent.
I look for five seconds and I give up.
There you go.
There is a clip.
Yeah, I saw the clip.
I don't know where I saw it.
I think I saw it on Twitter.
I don't even know where to look.
Alright, up we go.
I'm tired of all the battleship dungeons.
Oh, thank fucking God we made it.
Oh, it was on Reddit?
Oh, hey, there it is.
We are here.
Ow!
It doesn't make sense!
Didn't I tell you back at Staranis Gruins?
Emperor's New Groove meme.
Nobody is faster than me.
Oh my God.
It reminds me that Emperor's New Groove had no script.
Looks to me like victory is out.
Wait, what?
Wait, that's Dragon Ball Z.
It's Zaka!
Bro, he got fucking stabbed by a knife and he's okay?
He literally got slashed by a knife by a fucking mecha.
That was like 50 broken bones right there.
Wait, that's the Dragon Ball robot!
It's just a knife.
Oh shit.
The blade is really dull.
You don't understand, Doki.
Yeah, I saved your life.
Guys, we have a problem.
As in like all my robots have like very low HP.
Wait, it's the Dragon Ball Z robot with like Cell's tail.
Oh my God.
Battleship Defender.
That's what I'm saying!
How come now they fucking fight the fucking other general?
Fine.
Do what you need to.
Isn't that...
Whoa!
Bro, it's so fast!
That's right.
I can fly too.
What you gonna do?
Oh, miss.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's better if it gets closer to me.
Just cause like I can't aim on the tank.
Bro, it's okay.
That's fucking it.
Get in here.
Whoa!
I am not doing any damage.
Get in here, Raul.
I need help.
Raul!
I should have upgraded my tank!
Yeah!
I should have upgraded!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Guys, I don't...
Oh my God!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, okay.
Give me a sec.
We gonna armor up.
And then firepower.
Like, this is the only way.
I feel like...
I feel like we...
No!
Okay, I was gonna say it.
This is bullshit.
The moment I...
I have the power up for this and I miss every shot.
Woo!
Bro, this guy hits so hard!
What?!
Oh, this is very bad.
This is very bad.
Swap bots.
No!
I couldn't swap!
Oh no.
Does Cassine heal?
If it heals, I can go for...
Guys, it does not heal.
Guys!
Guys, it does not heal, guys.
That's awkward.
Oh no, I made this a lot harder.
Okay.
It's okay.
Holy shit.
I...
I made this a lot harder than I should have, guys.
Guys!
This is...
This is not good.
I definitely made this a lot harder.
Cooked unless...
Unless...
Okay, we can play this passively.
Nice.
We can do this.
Guys, there is...
There is hope for us.
I can take like two shots.
I can take so many shots, guys.
Woo!
If I just do this, we're fine.
Guys!
We might not be as fine as we thought.
Oh shit!
Holy shit.
Oh, no!
Looking good!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, okay.
Okay.
Oh, I have other tiers in my inventory!
Oh, thank god!
Okay.
Guys!
Oh my god!
Guys.
It's okay now.
That's fucking right.
I'm back, bitch!
I'm back!
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Thank you, backseating!
This is why I love backseating.
I love backseating!
Yay!
Okay, we gotta heal again.
Okay.
Backseating!
Yay!
Woo!
Okay, don't worry.
I can guard.
Oh, did you see that?
See that?
I can guard!
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Get over here!
I learned!
Zeon with the clutch!
Woo!
That's fucking right.
We're gonna do nothing!
Oh, shit!
Guys, hey!
Can you guys like help me out too?
What do you mean you can't help?
What do you mean?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna stay over here.
I can't believe he said he can't help me!
Wait, I can lock on target.
I forgot about that.
There we go.
Okay, don't worry.
Uppercut!
Yeah!
Boom!
Oh!
And then the finisher!
Nice!
Guard!
Okay.
We're good.
And then...
Boost!
And then uppercut!
And then downcut!
Yeah!
It's a fighting game now!
Let's go!
The combo launcher!
And we're gonna do about it...
Nothing!
Boom!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
It's okay.
I have all the heals.
Rylal, go in there!
Shoot your missile!
That's right!
Kill Rylal!
Don't kill me!
Oh, whoops!
I messed up that, but that's okay.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm gonna die.
Oh!
That's fucking right!
No!
Rylal, you don't get this!
Go for the grab!
Harvest him!
Harvest him and add him to my mecha collection!
...the core frame at least.
Hey, Terrain on your parade, but we don't have much time to spare now.
I know.
Let's get the Aquanium from the engine room.
R B plus A to make...
When the... what?
How did I get this upgrade?
How the fuck did the bezel buffs just suddenly learn how to metallize?
Like...
That came out of nowhere.
I just suddenly received the upgrade.
I know, I was like, what?
It was so nonchalant.
I just received it.
Out of nowhere.
I can't believe it.
I have other items in my inventory?
Holy shit chat.
Isn't that crazy?
We're the first ones to the engine room.
Which means we win!
Good.
I found the Aquanium.
I wonder if we'll ever see the sister.
Close the capsule valve, just like Pollock did.
There we go.
Now it shouldn't show up on the Aquanium radar.
Alright.
Let's report to Longo.
Eh?
We've gotta tell him there's no more need to come here.
Right.
We did it!
We got the thing!
We did our job!
Alright.
No, did...
Did she actually... wait, is she dead?
How could she be dead?
There's no way.
I feel like if she was dead, like, Beelzebub would be more sad.
I feel like.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
And I... I...
I feel like winning the King and her...
Yeah, I feel like...
She would... like, I would know if she was dead.
Okay.
We killed all...
Well, I feel like there wasn't...
There was no demons in Forest Land.
Because all the demons were in Sand Land.
Sand Land is like...
Patient...
Sand Land is like the origin of demons.
Apparently.
And everybody else were just invasive species.
Yeah, I feel like she has to be still alive.
Yeah, that's some Forest Land propaganda.
Apparently.
I can jump off?
Oh no, I just head downstairs.
I was like is that...
Is that just a fucking cliff?
Oh, Secret Item.
Secret...
Ta-da.
Fuck the Avatar Live Action Series.
I know that was out of nowhere, but...
I remember that song.
And Avatar.
The Live Action Series was fucking...
Shit.
It was just... it was just... I don't know.
I ranted about it before.
The Avatar live action.
Like yeah, the CGI was amazing.
But like...
The story was like...
The writing was not great.
I'll say it.
If the creators of Avatar left...
There was a... like I can see why.
I can see why they left.
Just the story was just... I hate what they did to Sokka.
Like he has barely any character development now because of...
Because they removed...
They removed his character development which was fucking weird.
I thought it was just weird.
I think he used a hover bot.
Oh my god!
My ride is not doing okay.
It's okay.
The cutscene will heal me.
The cutscene will heal me, guys!
I'll get to a cutscene!
There's no more bosses!
I'm pretty sure.
Right?
There can't be anymore bosses!
I saved your life!
You owe me now!
That's right.
Now you're my minion!
God, when you say Aquanium, it just doesn't fit.
Nobody fits with the Aquanium.
I'll follow you there... or anywhere.
Don't worry, sir.
You can make money through other means.
No, Beezabub!
What the fuck are you doing?
What the fuck?
The Aquanium is used to destroy the world?
Beezabub, you idiot!
The Aquanium is used to destroy the world!
And they're okay!
Later then.
How are they okay with it?
Like, they're just like, alright.
Before delivering this Aquanium to Supreme Commander Bread...
Yeah, but why is everyone okay with it?
We'll store it near Crump Army Research Lab, right?
Oh, I see.
That's right.
But we can't leave it there for long.
I see.
So it's not his fault if it gets stolen.
But how did he know that he would have followed along?
Now our official reports can wait.
Let's go see how Femons do it.
Bro, that was such a huge gamble.
He could have been like, fuck you guys.
It sounds like he's giving us a chance to nab it for ourselves.
Oh, really?
Yeah, that was such a huge gamble.
That man is something else.
Yeah, you don't know for sure if he fucking was gonna let us use it.
Okay, we need the water.
We're...
We need water right now.
Hey, there's Lito.
Where the heck is the water?
Okay, where's the water though?
Guys.
Where's... Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, apparently you can use... Maybe...
Maybe... Maybe I can like heal my car.
Can you heal my car?
Alright, nevermind.
Oh wait, there's like...
Wait, there's...
I'm surprised how many people live in the capital.
We can use this.
We can repair it.
We have... Oh yeah, we definitely have a lot.
Oh, why do I only... Oh, I need to go to a campsite.
Okay.
Yay!
Alright.
Now for some hard intel on the area.
Alright, there is like a spot over here.
So I wanna see what...
What materials it gives.
That must be like materials and stuff.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
The quaenium could only cause a couple war crimes.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Beelzebub, you are so stupid!
Alright, we unlock that.
Ooh!
More... More gear!
Okay.
Let's see.
Can I fast travel?
Oh, it's right... It's literally right here.
Alright.
Fast travel.
Oh, there's a camp too!
Wait, that's good!
Alright, we gotta rest.
For the first time, we're resting.
Oh my god.
For the first time in years, we decided to rest.
I wanna see if my car is better.
Yeah, my car is better.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
Motorcycle time.
Wait, another mom showed up?
Not anymore.
Now you're orphans again.
Get adopted by another mom!
I'll make sure you'll always be orphans.
Oh, shit!
Alright.
That's awkward.
Guys, I gotta go back.
Guys, it's not karma.
But I need to go back upstairs.
I need to heal my bike again, guys.
Give me a sec.
Now I can fast travel!
Okay, maybe?
No.
Come on.
Get out!
Get out of here!
Alright, I should be able to fast travel now.
Still not?
Okay, now I should be... Okay, it doesn't matter.
I'm at the camp.
It doesn't matter.
Okay, rest.
There we go.
See, we're okay!
Never punished, guys!
Never fucking punished!
Okay, where do we have to go?
Okay, it's this way.
What's that?
Oh, they're like ores.
We don't need ores.
We have so much of them.
Yay!
I love not getting punished for my actions!
That means I can still keep doing them!
Yay!
Does everybody in Forestland have bots or something?
Let's get rid of these guys.
I'm gonna punch a tiger.
Watch this.
It's like punching a kangaroo.
There you go.
That's right.
Oh, you wanna join in too?
I'm gonna punch a sucky second tiger.
What the fuck are you guys doing here?
This isn't your fight!
I'm gonna swat you like flies!
Get over here!
You wanna fucking go?
Well, punch a bird too!
That's fucking right.
Alright, now... back on the bike.
Back on the bike I go.
I need to reload.
Alright, these guys don't matter to me.
Gotta head over there.
Alright, up we go.
And...
This way.
God!
With all these mechs, why don't I have one that flies?
That's like the... literally the only thing we're missing.
I seriously doubt that.
Bots are expensive to buy and maintain.
No one talked to you, Ral.
Normal people couldn't hope to afford them.
Only the army is rich.
Wait, it heard me!
Oh my god!
The game's listening!
Hey, Krola!
We came...
Getting right to the point, I see.
That said, it's not like I can just hand this over to you for free.
So how do we settle this?
How about... with that one-on-one...
It becomes self-aware!
Guys, I told you guys this is why I don't play more than three parts of a video game!
It starts becoming self-aware!
...the spot that gives me the edge.
Surely the leader of the demons wouldn't mind such a small handicap.
Wait, what's the handicap?
Actually, the leader of the demons is Lucifer.
Fine!
I'll take you on anywhere!
There's a place just west of here.
A Rashia village.
We're gonna fucking storm a village?
I'll be waiting for you right outside town.
Bro, they're like, let's get somewhere safe for this right outside a village that all these civilians live.
You'd better be ready too.
I want our duel to be legendary.
Alright.
Oh hey, there's more water!
Okay, it's this way.
Look!
Like, how is that safe?
We're literally in another...
Like, I don't understand how that's safe.
We're like in somebody else's town.
How is that safer?
Safe for us, not for them.
Yeah.
That's all I was thinking.
I was like, bro, what?
Alright.
We'll take that.
And then we'll take that.
And down we go.
We actually... let's just...
I mean, we could.
Technically, there's loot there too.
The civilians are just props.
It's like Street Fighter or Tekken where like, you include the civilians into the fight.
The environment damage.
We gotta include the environment!
Okay, this way.
Open!
Okay, whoa, that's a big rocket launcher.
I mean, we have so much materials because I don't repair anything.
Nice!
Okay, so I assume...
Wait, how do we get there?
Holy shit, they're so far!
Wait, how the fuck do I get there?
I wish we do have planes.
I can't believe Ral said we're not rich enough to have a plane.
I mean, to be fair, he's right.
I'm a demon.
Like, we don't have the sense of currency.
But still...
Still not fair!
Alright.
Okay.
I found out I don't take fall damage, so...
This stinks!
Nevermind.
Okay, okay.
Okay, apparently in Sand Land you don't take fall damage.
That's actually fucking bullshit.
In Sand Land you don't take fall damage.
But Forest Land is different.
Okay, I guess I have to do this bullshit then.
Let me hug the wall.
Alright, now it should work.
Whoa!
There we go!
Alright.
Alright, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Sorry.
Forest Land has its own gravity apparently.
Apparently Forest Land has its own special gravity that doesn't exist in Sand Land.
Which is great.
That's great to know now.
That's great to know.
This is what I'm gonna do.
Come into the cave.
That's right.
He's too small for the cave.
Okay, get out!
Get out!
Whoa!
Get out of my cave!
Okay, nice.
Oh!
That dodge though!
That dodge was fucking sick!
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Guys, I went the wrong way.
Oh my god, no.
Not that much.
Elite Panther?
Where?
Guys,
there.
Alright, take two.
It's okay.
Take two.
I went the wrong way anyway.
We were supposed to go this way.
Alright, we were not supposed to go to any shortcuts apparently.
Okay.
The shortcut was not needed because there was no need to take a shortcut.
Because I went the wrong way.
I almost steal your loot.
Yay.
Alright, goodbye.
I just wanted to steal their loot.
Alright.
Take two!
Guys, we've only fucked up once.
So this is the second take.
Wait, it's just...
Okay, Hovercar does like the most damage, what I've realized.
Hey, LC.
And we get snake stuff too!
Okay.
Ooh, platinum ore!
There we go.
And then- Oh, there's more ore!
That's good.
Okay, and then... more ore.
Oh, it was just iron ore.
We don't need iron ore.
Alright.
And then... swap cars!
Bike tab.
Yay!
Guys, we're doing it, guys!
Take two!
There was never a take three- I don't know why you guys keep saying take three.
Do I save his life?
You know what?
I feel kind today.
Oh my god, they were so weak.
They literally are literally just... little birds.
Alright, give me your shit.
Give me your loot right now.
What do I get?
Nice.
Money.
I didn't do it out of the goodness of my heart.
I did it because I like money.
I'm gonna get it.
Let's see...
Go this way, I assume.
How do I get there?
Oh, this way.
There's a bridge.
Yay!
And then there's more bridges.
This is such a far village!
Why couldn't we just fight there?
There was like- I don't understand why he- why Elvis wouldn't just let me fight there.
No!
Supa-San, look at the-
I saw loot above me!
I was like, ooh!
How do I get up there?
Okay.
I was like, whoa!
What's that?
Okay, I can walk up.
There's stairs.
Yay!
Alright, nice.
Okay.
This better be worth it.
Lore.
Crow romance?
Okay, now I have to read it.
A book that's seen better days.
Found near the village suspension bridge.
Parts are illegible due to exposure of the elements.
Crow romance, volume 5.
The novel spins the tale of a prince crow and an impoverished girl named Off-Key falling in love.
They made five books of this?
It is pretty good, but the best parts all smudged.
Looks like the letters bled due to a ring.
Dang, now I need to know how it ends.
Its owner might be nearby.
Perhaps they'll tell you the ending if you bring- Wait, what?
So like, is it like an actual bird?
And a chi- and a- and a- and a- and a woman?
And a human?
And they made five books of that?
I'm a little confused at the part where like, it literally says, crow.
So a bird and a woman fall in love.
Guys, you can't just say it's like, princess and the frog, cause the princess turned into the frog.
So it made more sense.
But this one, it's like full bird.
Is that how CrowKey was born?
Thank you for the super chat, Doug.
Thank you, thank you.
CrowKey is a full crow!
Wait, oh there he is.
Sorry, I was- I didn't realize that was him.
I thought that was my crew.
Okay.
Let me check on parking.
I'm parallel parking right now.
I won't stay in my bike while I talk to you.
Alright.
The perfect spot for our contest is up ahead.
Follow me.
Holy shit, he walks so slow.
So tell me.
What are you doing?
RUN!
Uh, dunno.
You wanna handle this one, thief?
Let's see.
Well, we've lived on this world long before humanity even existed.
Think of us as your venerable ancestors.
Wow.
So you're like the original people of our world?
I knew it!
They were the invasive species this entire time!
So, you can see Supreme Commander Bread and Moonie- They're Christopher Columb- Okay, I shouldn't say that.
They want nothing to do with this annoying conflict they're forcing on us.
You're not thinking of one.
Sorry.
Are you?
Hey, we're not monsters.
Leave us out of your dumb wars.
What?
Supreme Commander Bread is always telling us that demons are the best.
Demons are the baddest of the bad.
But I'm starting to think that can't be true.
Exactly.
Demons aren't the bad guys at all.
I agree.
They might have the purest hearts of anyone in this world.
Our hearts are pure, alright?
Pure evil.
Bro, can I walk faster?
RUN!
You're thinking, haven't you?
About which side is right and which is wrong?
It won't even let me stray the path.
Right is relative after all.
Why do I walk to the left?
Nope, it won't let me see that!
I try to walk to the left and the game forces me to walk straight.
After all this, you really still think Bread is in the right?
You're... the princess, right?
Under normal circumstances, I'd be at your command.
But these times sure as hell aren't nice.
I'm normal and I answer only to Supreme Commander Bread.
I owe him for taking us in when we had nothing to our name.
Wait, what?
Orphans?
Oh, he's an orphan!
What?!
To me, honor is more important than being right.
This is getting a little unethical because they took him into the army when they were little when they had nothing.
So they're orphans and like, you know...
I'm not sure what you're expecting.
All I'm saying... wait, there was loot behind me.
I'm gonna go back to get the loot.
All I'm saying is that... is that... is that they've been gaslighted into joining the army.
Is there loot?
I thought there'd be loot!
So like, he's been in the army... I'm not saying... I'm not saying that he might be a child soldier.
All I'm saying is that he said he had nowhere to go and he was young.
So... I'm saying that the army might need some explaining to do about this army.
Right here.
Now then, let's get started.
Yup.
You guys just let me handle this.
All right.
Wait, what?
Where did this guy... oh, wait, I thought it was a 1v1!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck kind of 1v1 is this?!
He fucking gets to ride a bike and I just...
Get rowdy here.
No!
Get over here!
Okay, he has a set... oh my god, I punched a bike.
That's fucking right.
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
That's right, go punch a fucking bike!
Okay, maybe not.
1v1 me, you coward!
Okay, this is bad.
I don't... okay, it's like the bike thing all over again.
It's definitely like the bike thing all over again.
It's okay!
I'll get there!
I know the pattern!
I know the pattern, guys!
Guys, I know where he's gonna go!
I know where he's gonna go, guys!
I swear to god, I know where he's gonna go!
No!
Okay, this is awkward.
This is actually...
This is a little awkward, guys.
This is... this is just a little...
Look, see, I knew it!
Oh shit!
Okay, I tank like...
I tanked a lot of that.
Okay.
Well, maybe... maybe punch guy.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Wait, a 1v1 isn't like rounds.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, row, please!
Please row!
Yeah!
I punched him one time!
Whoa!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can shoot him too!
See?
BL, don't give up!
Ow!
What?
Does it look like I'm giving up?
Does it... does it look like I'm giving up?
I'm actually trying.
I don't know why she thinks I'm giving up.
I don't know why she thinks I'm giving up, guys.
I thought...
I thought I was trying!
Okay, we're just gonna...
Oh!
No!
What do you mean don't throw?
I'm trying my best!
There we go!
I got one hit in.
Guys, look.
Guys.
I got a hit.
A hit's a hit!
Okay, nice.
Wait, I'll just chase after it!
I have... Stop!
I'm trying!
I actually am trying it!
I know... I know it doesn't look like it, but I'm actually trying.
BL, don't give up!
Please, Adam!
Try my best!
I'm not giving up!
Okay.
There is so many missiles coming in.
No!
Please!
There's so many missiles!
Okay.
Please.
We're so... Guys, we are so close!
Close.
Guys, don't worry.
It's working.
What do you mean, stop?
I'm trying!
Tank time.
Maybe it's...
It's okay.
Tank time.
Oh, it's okay, guys.
It's tank time.
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
It's absolutely not.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, what I learned is that I was doing the best with the mecha.
Oh, see?
He could die!
I told you!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm not doing so well.
This is the hardest fight ever.
This is actually the hardest one.
Oh, please.
Please!
Leave
me alone!
Oh, my God.
I'm trying!
Leave me alone!
Okay.
Stop trying!
There's so many missiles!
Oh, my God!
I'm trying my best!
Maybe it's jump bot time.
Maybe if I just jump...
Jump all my problems away.
Okay.
That's some nice speed you've got there.
If I just jump from...
From all my problems, guys.
Jump!
Oh, my God!
The jump bot!
Okay.
Maybe if I ride my bike.
Maybe I'll just ride my bike.
This is it.
Guys, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
I can outrun this.
So annoying.
Guys, I figured...
Holy shit!
I have a feeling...
I have...
Guys, I don't think I figured it out, guys.
I don't think I...
Guys, I don't think I figured it out.
Don't give up!
It's looking like a not figuring it out scenario.
I'm not doing this.
I can't upgrade it.
It's too late.
I started the 1v1.
I'm in too deep.
I can't.
I started it.
Now I have to end it with my life.
Don't give up.
Please, Adam.
I'm trying not to.
I messed up it.
Get ready for your funny episode.
Oh shit!
Don't give up.
Oh my god, Ann.
It's not by choice.
It was never by choice.
Holy shit.
Do I even have it?
Guys...
Oh no.
This is not good.
Wait, I still have one more ...
I'm very good.
I'm kidding.
Okay, wait, strength...
Temporary Brute... Oh, nice!
Guys, we need to wait.
Where is the firepower?
Okay, we got firepower and we got armor.
This is it.
We go all in, guys.
We go all in.
Get over here!
Go to the lane!
Please!
No!
Please, I have so many upgrades right now.
Please!
Oh my God!
Guys!
Does this hit me if I block it?
No, it doesn't.
Oh, never mind.
It does.
If I could grab, I would.
No, no.
This is like the most unfair fight ever.
I swear to God, this fight is actually so unfair.
Let's take this fight up another tier, BielsaBub.
Please.
Please leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Lock it in, princess.
Alright.
Boom!
And then I block.
I can't block.
Oh my God!
Fuck you, Karr!
Holy shit.
Oh my God, I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Bro, this guy doesn't play fair!
Oh God.
Oh, what do you mean?
I haven't hit him once.
What do you mean, just a little more?
Yes!
Okay.
I take those.
I take anything I can get at this point.
Oh God.
I can't run.
Guys, I can't run.
Oh my God.
Punch King!
No!
Woo!
Oh God.
Oh my God.
That's so many missiles.
Oh my God!
Oh!
Holy shit!
Okay.
No!
He was so close!
Okay.
Get him!
Oh God.
I have to take this slow and steady.
Take this slow and steady.
Okay.
Oh no, he's doing that thing again.
He's doing that thing again.
Oh, he's doing that thing!
Oh!
Woo!
Oh shit.
Punch!
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Let's just poke him.
Oh God.
Not again.
Please.
Do I still...?
Do I still have armor?
Nice!
I do!
Oh no, I'm overheating!
Oh no.
This is bad!
Okay.
Take this!
No!
Don't take it!
Come on!
No!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Fuck!
No!
Oh my god I fucked up!
I almost fucked up!
Holy fuck!
No I don't have nitro!
I don't have nitro anymore!
Discord nitro!
Oh no!
Oh god!
I have to like...
Make sure I have enough nitro for this.
Oh god!
Bro I'm so stressed out!
No!
I overheated!
Oh god!
No!
Oh!
I can't!
Do I have anything that has...
Guys... guys this is not looking so good.
Oh my god.
Guys... guys this is not looking so good anymore.
This is actually... oh god!
Fuck!
Get in!
No!
Holy shit!
I can't!
Guys!
This is really bad!
This is actually really bad!
Fuck!
No!
We were so close!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
This is actually so bullshit!
Oh my god!
This... this fucking... this guy!
This guy!
Bro I hate this car!
I actually hate this car!
Holy shit!
I think we got the system!
I think!
I think we got it!
We figured it out!
We figured it out guys!
Oh fuck please!
We figured it out!
I'll just shoot him with my gun!
That's it!
Boom!
Okay we figured it out guys!
We just gotta believe!
The missile spam may be a lot!
How does he have so many missiles?
Like where is the government mutt?
This is where it's going!
Oh my god!
We did it guys!
We've cracked the code!
Boom!
Oh shit!
We cracked the code guys!
Okay.
We cracked the code!
Alright.
There we go.
It's like I might need to upgrade my tank guys.
Guys who would have thought not upgrading anything would end up fucking me over guys.
Guys!
Can you guys believe it?
Oh god.
You think?
Yeah.
Yeah guys we might need to upgrade our tank!
We might need to start upgrading.
It's like I'm under leveled as hell right now.
Oh my god.
He's running me over!
It's not fair!
Okay.
I'm trying to... Yes!
I'm trying.
I really am.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
These missiles are so fucking fast!
Okay.
And I need you to know that I am not... I'm not actually fucking around.
I am trying my hardest.
Actually the hardest fight ever.
This is actually the hardest fight.
I had to deal with it.
Okay.
Repair kit.
Alright.
We're gonna put the repair... Oh shit!
Okay.
Never mind.
Alright.
We still have... Okay.
We have armor.
We have fire power.
We have...
Okay.
Boom.
There we go.
Get over here.
Get over here so I can shoot you down!
Oh shit!
Okay.
We just gotta believe!
No!
Guys, we just gotta believe, guys!
Oh god.
Please!
Please just keep on believing, guys!
Okay.
Boom!
Oh my god.
Took so much damage from that.
That one hit.
Oh no.
No, no.
No!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Alright.
That was sick maneuver though.
That was a sick maneuver though.
Okay.
No!
I missed!
That took so much damage!
No!
Okay.
Yes I know, Beelzebub!
Yes I know!
I know I'm catching fire!
I don't know what else to do!
Beelzebub, please!
I know!
Oh no, I've overheated again.
I need a balance!
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh please, how many more armors do I have?
Oh no.
Where's my repair kits?
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Here we go.
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Oh!
Holy fuck!
That was not worth it!
No!
That hurt a lot!
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Dodge!
Wooo!
Please do your spinny attack, sir!
Do it!
Okay, nice.
Oh, thank god.
Wooo!
Okay, he's doing his spinny attack.
That's good.
That's good for us.
Oh god, I can't even shoot my gun!
What?!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit!
Okay, there you go.
At least you know I'm trying my best, sir.
You know I'm trying my best, guy.
After this, I'll level up my tank.
I promise!
I promise, Dracos!
I'll level up my tank after this!
I learned my lesson!
Okay.
No!
Nice.
I learned my lesson, everybody.
Never again.
Never again!
Oh my god.
Oh!
No!
I can't even punch him!
Oh no.
Okay, nice.
I can only do like, a little bit of poke... before.
THIEF, YOU SAID THAT 30 MINUTES AGO!
I feel like that's not
- It doesn't feel like it!
It doesn't feel like a little bit more anymore!
Oh god.
No!
No I got too cocky!
This always happens!
Whenever I get a little too cocky.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm slapping him with a stick.
There's nothing else I can do!
We have to wheedle the damage very slowly!
If I... If I just have to, that's all I can do.
The stick play is all I have.
It's literally all I have.
Very slowly.
It's like level 1 versus level 99 right now.
Thief please.
I feel like I heard that forever.
Thief.
The more he says it, the less I believe it's a little more.
Oh shit!
Okay.
We can't punch guys.
We punch!
Okay we can't get... No!
Oh god.
It's done!
Oh my god.
I'm back.
Oh please!
He's so close!
No!
He needs to spin!
Please!
Start spinning, Fritz!
Start spinning!
That's the only time I can do any damage!
Okay but not right now.
Oh god.
Not right now though but okay.
I didn't mean now but that's alright.
I wasn't prepared for the spin.
But that's okay.
Oh my god I can see the light!
Guys I can see the light!
It's almost there!
I can see the light!
Wait.
Wait it's the time.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it!
Oh thank god!
Oh my god.
Thank you.
I'm so over it.
It's over.
Hey okay I'm over it.
Off with the aquarium.
Oh my god it's over.
I could be special ops.
A staff officer.
Maybe a servant like you.
Ugh!
Because you are!
You have no other purpose!
Whoa!
Sliding in that quick, Elvis?
Princess, I don't think that's a good idea.
Whoa!
Okay, that's smooth.
Never mind.
That was smooth, though.
Never have I seen so many mishaps.
Pong, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
This guy's very first super chat and then they're like, what the fuck is going on?
Damn!
That's so smooth.
Bro's got game.
Oh, bread.
Also, bread's not a woman!
Wait, what?
You're not gonna join us after all that?
But that was so smooth!
Whoa!
General Kroa!
Yeah, he'll get in touch, alright.
Actually sliding into your DMs.
Yeah.
He should just give us that car.
The bullshit I just said.
I just went through.
I deserve to own that car.
Bread is about to make a move?
Even when losing, he is winning.
Oh my god.
Whoops, sorry.
I don't need a passport.
Alright, let's go back to...
Let's go back to Lango.
Okay, where's the garage?
Give me a sec.
I need...
This is more important.
Give me a sec.
After everything I went through, give me a sec.
Okay, let's upgrade this.
And then...
I feel like I should upgrade the battle too.
Like...
Okay.
Alright.
Um...
And then after that, we gotta upgrade our parts.
Yeah.
Let's... Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
Ooh, it's purple!
Wait, okay.
Primary... Whoa.
Wait, that shit is...
Wait, that's...
That's a lot.
Is that a lot of damage?
Okay, that's a lot of damage.
The cannon?
Wait.
Shot explo...
Enchanted...
Artillery.
Wait, should we get the...
I'm gonna get the cannon.
It's purple.
And then...
The super...
Guys.
Wow.
Who...
Who would've thought I was so behind when it came...
Oh my god.
There was a lot of stuff.
We needed to do...
That...
Guys, there was a lot of upgrades.
Okay, we're gonna do the battle armor.
Let's see.
Do we have anything?
Oh, we do.
Okay.
Armored legs.
Yeah, I think defense is good.
Wait, we have a cannon too?
Wait a minute.
That's a lot of upgrades.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay, that was...
That was a lot more than I expected.
That was...
That was a lot bigger upgrades than I expected, guys.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, I should've gone back to camp.
Is there anything upgraded here?
Holy shit!
Alright.
Okay.
There was a lot of stuff I should've been doing.
Should I upgrade everything?
Interceptor, drones, slam into enemies while engulfed in flames?
Okay, yeah, we need that.
Alright.
Okay, we need upgrade...
We gotta upgrade this guy too.
Uhhhh...
Upgrade vehicle.
Okay.
I can get it to 16.
Oh my god.
Okay, we don't care about this guy apparently.
Holy shit.
Wow.
Alright, we need croc alloy.
Alright!
I think our vehicles are pretty...
Oh wait, I can upgrade like parts too.
I forgot about that.
Parts.
Upgrade part.
Nevermind.
I need a lot of shit.
How about my...
This guy.
Okay, I need cobra alloy, arm scrap, crack alloy.
Okay, I need snakes and...
Alright.
Wait, how do I upgrade chip slots?
Parts.
Make part.
Wait, what the fuck?
I can make stuff?
Wait, but how do I get chip slots?
Oh, upgrade vehicle?
Oh, there you go.
Wait, I can't.
It's locked.
I think I need to be a level higher.
I need to be level higher.
I think.
Because I can't get a chip slot.
Because there's no other way to...
I need to... yeah, I need to upgrade...
Let me... let me do a vehicle.
Upgrade vehicle.
Can I buy it here?
Yeah, I have to... oh, what level do you have to beat up?
You can't even have more than one!
Oh, I don't have magnets.
Is it because I need magnets?
I need a magnet?!
How the fuck do I find a magnet?!
Do you sell magnets?
Oh, hey, you got... how the...
Do you have magnets?
Petit Eric, do you have magnet?
Okay, we gotta buy repair kit.
No matter what people say.
B-grade shipping...
Okay, armor up, armor up, repair kit, repair kit plus.
Okay.
This is where we need to spend our money on.
This is...
Okay, this is definitely what we need to spend our money on.
Hey...
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, I don't care if I'm poor now.
After all of that, I realized what I need to do.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, now...
Wait, workshop?
Maybe you have magnets?
You have a magnet?
Oh, there he is!
What is this?
Oh shit!
Wait, I can buy so much stuff!
Okay, we need croc alloy and cobra alloy.
We can get all that.
And then... Oh my... guys!
Guys, I'm upgrading!
Alright, get back here.
Over here, everything I went through... I realized my mistake, guys.
Okay, this guy... Okay, croc steel.
Oh, I need a croc steel.
Quality cobra alloy?
My shit's not quality enough?!
Wait a minute!
Quality cobra alloy.
Quality gear.
Raptor alloy.
Scorpion.
Cobra alloy.
Croc... Oh, there it is.
Wait, what's the difference between... Oh...
What?!
They're saying our desert crocodiles aren't quality enough!
Fucking forest lander.
Goddamn forest lander!
They think our crocodiles are not quality enough?!
How fucking dare they?!
Goddamn forest lander.
They think they're above us!
They think they're above the sad landers!
Actually fucked up!
Good.
Guys, I need to buy croc steel too.
Goddamn it!
B grade steel.
There's so many parts I need.
Typical forest lander!
They think they're so much better than us!
Okay, we're not upgrading our fucking bike, I guess.
Wait, wait.
No croc hot.
No!
The bike is so sad.
Okay, parts.
Upgrade parts.
Okay, level two.
And then...
Wait, uh...
Oh, I can max it out.
I might as well.
Oh, fuck it.
Uh, well, I mean, chip stock is like a magnet, so we're fine.
Wait, which one am I using?
Jump bot.
Hopper?
I don't even own a hopper.
Is the hopper better than my jump bot?
Oh well, we'll now figure that out.
Robot.
Robotic arm scrap.
Oh, I haven't been killing those, I guess.
Uhhhh...
I mean, can I upgrade that?
Oh, I can!
Nice!
Oh, hopper is bad?
Okay, that's good to know.
Uhhhh... I don't have a hover jet.
There's a hover jet?
I mean...
I need large launcher scrap.
Okay, I don't have that, though.
I can upgrade this, though.
Okay, nice.
Uhhhh...
Okay.
Alright.
And then... vehicle.
Guys, this is crazy.
Upgrading stuff is so crazy now.
Guys, oh my god.
I need more money!
Nooo!
I spent all my money!
Good.
Alright.
I think we're upgraded enough for now.
Lungo?
Keep watching.
Watch what?
At long last, King Jam has admitted the error of his ways.
Moreover, he has agreed to cede the throne to Mooniel.
To the child?
And this is the proof.
How does it look?
Certainly screams royal heirloom, doesn't it?
When King Jam entrusted me with this treasure, I had no choice but to...
Oh!
He stole this from us!
To his will that I replace him as ruler of forest land and defend its people!
Bro, what a little brat!
I'm gonna fucking... punt this fucker.
It is for us, the people of forest land.
That Mooniel has assumed this heavy burden.
From this day forth, we must accept Mooniel as our one true sovereign.
The coronation shall be held in the palace square immediately.
This isn't good.
He sounds like some Call of Duty kid.
Sounds like a squeaker!
Confirmed legitimacy.
Now they're stealing my father's position by force, just like they stole the necklace!
If we don't counter their narrative, they win.
Why not just use the radio tower like before?
If we contact your news office, can they help us reach out to the people directly?
Certainly.
No.
The media is for the homies lapdog for the last time.
It is propaganda!
They have the media!
They control the media!
But will the people even listen to a plea made through such violent measures?
Yeah, and from a fiend to half a fiend.
What if they see I'm alive?
I'm sure they'll pay attention.
I doubt they'll like hearing you, you badass.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying, Udo.
Sorry, princess.
What happened, chapon?
Yeah, what happened?
I'm sorry, princess.
It's not just a coronation at the same time!
They're gonna execute King Cam!
No!
Chapon, this is no time for jokes.
I'm not joking!
Rumors are spreading all over town!
There's just no way.
Surely not even bread would go that far.
There's no point in speculating.
Hortos infiltrated the art.
The army will ask him when he returns.
Until then, we sit tight.
You mean they'll execute... my father?
Now, now.
We don't know that for sure yet.
Let's rest up while we wait for more information.
Oh no.
We gotta stop him!
Why is there like three different people?
Speak with... oh, here everyone.
Oh, we gotta make a choice.
Which one's the most violent choice?
I expect Muniel will invade Sandland as soon as he's been crowned.
And if he can finally achieve...
You need Jam with Bread!
...conquering Sandland.
Even those who disapprove of Bread's methods will side with him.
That is the absolute worst case scenario for us.
I didn't want to say this in front of Anne, but the loss of her necklace was a problem.
It's allowed them to make it look like King Jam.
Okay, I think everybody can see that.
I don't know if the part about the execution is...
Everybody sort of knows that the necklace was some air shit.
There's no way to keep the king alive anymore.
Father...
All because I lost that necklace.
Why would they want Sandland?
We have nothing there!
I wanted to leave Sandland because there was nothing there!
Good work, Korto.
So...
Is the rumor about the execution true?
Yeah.
We have sand at the beach!
The generals couldn't stop talking about it.
They were clearly shaken.
The executions were supposed to happen before the ceremony.
Longo...
Don't worry.
It's time for the Resistance to rescue King Jam!
Yeah!
I hate to be a downer.
But do we even have a strategy?
We don't need strategy!
We have a tank!
Only one kind of plan works well with our numbers.
It's back to diversion and infiltration.
Oh yeah, guys.
We're gonna get a whole bunch of them.
I.e.
five people.
We'll use the secret entrance...
...to the royal family...
...to reach the palace square.
And the diversion?
With the king being held hostage, any drastic moves could put his life at risk.
The diversion will come after the rescue...
...to provide the infiltration team with an escape route.
Ah!
Have you lost your minds?
That's it.
Where are you?
Are you gonna leave?
But you supported the Resistance for so long!
Only a total moron would run right into it.
Yeah, just back out now!
You're in too deep!
You have no choice.
Oh.
Well, be my guest.
Just don't expect us to join in.
Nooooooo swimmers!
Come back!
No point in trying to force them.
But...
We need you guys to swim!
We don't want to make anyone take part against their will.
Well, I guess I'll sit this one out too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why can't I just bring my demon army?
No, my watch.
Why can't I just bring dad over?
Like, we have a motive and be like, bro, he killed your child.
I knew it.
Just bring the demon army and get the demon army involved.
We've been fighting the good fight for an entire decade now.
Let's show bread just how much we've learned about guerrilla tactics over these past ten years.
I'm gonna call my dad.
Yeah!
Me and our three people in the Resistance.
Let's go.
We'll work out the details in the field.
Ew.
Why can't I just fucking call my dad?
Be like, dad!
They killed your fucking only daughter!
Okay.
Where's this?
Alright, nice.
Sadly, our bike is not leveled up.
But it's okay.
Our bike is still fast.
We don't need a level up or bike.
Alright, I'm ready.
Everything is leveled up now.
Where's everyone else?
They spread out near the capital to cause a diversion.
I was hoping you'd assist as well.
I don't mind, but what about rescuing King Jam?
That's where I come in.
You?
On your own?
That's crazy!
Oh?
I'll show you just how wily this old fox can be.
What's he gonna do?
He always managed to evade me in your rebel army days.
Huh.
That's kind of impressive.
But Brett and Mooniel are probably waiting at the palace plaza.
We'll need more than speed if we want to save the king.
Any human who could beat Lilith will surely be a match for the prince too.
I still don't buy that she actually lost.
But if she did, Thief's right.
So I'm gonna go and rescue her.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure she's still alive.
There's no way.
Just how strong this Mooniel is.
Mooniel's like a fucking child.
How could he beat up my sister?
Aren't we supposed to be rescuing my father?
I know that.
I'll rescue him along the way.
Along the way?
Then it's decided.
I'll leave the infiltration to you.
Much appreciated.
We can reach the plaza using the secret passage under that bridge.
There's a secret passage?
Then what are we waiting for?
Let's go!
Yeah!
Oh, this is gonna be easy.
Okay.
Wait, where's the secret passage?
Okay, I'll go to the capital and then get over there.
Where's the secret passage?
Is it?
Oh, it's under this bridge.
Okay.
Not too bad.
It should be like here, right?
Yeah!
I'm so smart.
Wait, where do I go?
Where the fuck am I?
This way?
It's been ten years since I last came through here.
There's a fucking village?
Next to the secret passage?
Not so secret.
I'm not using it to run away this time.
Huh?
Is that it?
Shhh.
Seems there's still some time before the coronation starts.
We wait here until it begins.
That's really nice that they're giving like six feet.
Wait, is that...?
Is that Dad?
Holy shit, that's a fucking guillotine.
A scaffold?
Never before has such a glorious day smiled upon forest land.
And yet, so too is it a day of mourning.
Dad with his khakis.
You guys wait here.
I'm going in alone.
Is being king like a white collar job?
Like, what is this?
He looks like an office man.
That is a righteous idea, even for you.
We'll get caught if we all go.
I just gotta sneak up to Anne's dad, grab him, and make a break for it, right?
Be careful.
If the guards see you, it's all over.
I know that.
I feel like that's not him.
I don't know.
King Jam was a good ruler.
But it is a sad truth that it takes only a single drop of mud to befoul even the purest water.
Tempted by a fiend, King Jam committed a grave crime.
It's okay.
It's cutscene stealth.
That means I don't have to worry, guys.
It's cutscene stealth, guys.
He must pay for his crimes.
Thank God.
For prizes.
I'm going to get a fire to the coronation.
We shall be holding the execution of King Jam.
I thought I gave my necklace to the child.
So why are we executing me?
Or executing the king?
Demon?
Take aim!
Quick, use your metallic power!
We gotta split!
Fire!
This isn't what we agreed on.
You promised you wouldn't really shoot!
I knew it!
It can't be him!
I was like, why is he just wearing fucking khakis and a fucking...
business shirt?
It's not my father!
It was a trap after all!
Run!
I knew something was off!
Here you go!
Something for you to remember me by!
I'm going to get you!
Whoa!
Why you little demon!
Don't touch me!
He reminds me of fucking...
It was like...
I'll...
I'll tell my father about you!
I won't waste my time fighting you filthy demons again!
What in the world is going on here?
We knew we might be walking into a trap.
But not on this scale.
Is that...
The forest land army?
The resistance was supposed to distract us!
Hey, where's the resistance?
Who exactly?
You mean this one?
You mean the five people?
Three?
What a fucking distraction!
Wow!
You make me just a little more trouble!
An army of five!
Three!
Not so!
Three old people!
All right, for it!
They're gonna shoot him!
Let a single one get away!
Why are they shooting?
What?
Hello?
Don't let him get away!
Now it's four!
What for you and you and you!
Great!
Now, this is our chance to escape!
If only they had a weapon!
If only they had a gun of some sort!
Oh my god!
If only!
Wait!
I can't...
Can't help right now!
What do you mean I can't bring out my tank?
Guys, this is unfair.
I actually have to use my arms.
I can't believe it, I did ALL OF THAT and now I have to fight?!
This is fucked up.
Where are they?
Oh... sorry.
I can't believe it.
What's the point?
I spent all my time upgrading my... my tank and had to use my arms?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
Wow, where did he come from?
Are you serious?
It's a stick!
Why is he raising his hands up as if he's gonna get shot?
Now, foul fiend!
Unless you want your friends to lose their heads, get on your knees and grovel before me!
If I do, will you promise to let them go unharmed?
Perhaps.
I'll consider letting you go.
God, what a little bitch.
This voice actor is really good at making us hate this character.
I can't read this guy's mind either.
What'll it be, fiend?
Better start begging before I run out of patience.
It's a stick!
Why are you scared?
What the?
Get it together, Beelzebub!
You aren't allowed to admit defeat to anyone other than us, the Swimmers!
Swimmers, shoot him!
Why did he shoot the floor?
He could've literally shot the Muneo kid right there.
This would have been over.
After them.
Do not let them escape!
Swimmers, you could have shot... you could have shot them.
That's all I'm saying.
He could've literally shot the Muneo kid and all of this would have been over.
Okay, I wasn't gonna kill anybody but you were annoying.
Alright, the story would have ended there, exactly.
How is my team doing?
Oh yeah, you're gonna cheer me on instead of running with me?
Okay.
Yeah.
What plan?
Yeah, our assault team of three.
How did this war last 10 years is a cool question.
Well, they seldom worked on the great General Shiva.
Surely you suspected something was up this time as well.
The possibility did occur to me and to the Prince.
The fact that this war has lasted 10 years surprised me, guys.
We sure didn't expect it to be this.
That was insane.
We almost died out there.
It was a stick!
But it was a huge success in the end.
Isn't that what matters?
You call this a huge success?
My father turned out to be a fake.
And all we managed to do was run away without getting hurt.
What was the point of all that?
Well, one good thing came out of it.
Wait, what?
What good thing?
Oh, they got the necklace!
They got the heir!
A fair haspik key.
It's a key to a ship or something.
I mean, it's literally key shaped.
He did a thing!
Without definitive proof of the King's abdication, they might postpone the coronation.
Way to go, thief!
Ugh!
Honestly, you lot.
It's a little too early to celebrate.
Mr. Thief is right.
We won't have resolved anything until King Jam is safe and sound.
We need to know where he is, though.
Where is he?
Contact Trick Camp and hurry along the preparations.
I tried contacting them, but they're not answering.
Wait, what's going on at our camp?
The communicator's working fine.
That's strange.
That's not good.
Head back.
Yes, sir.
That does sound odd.
We'll come to the camp soon.
To be fair, we brought the entire army.
A three.
Thanks.
To this plan.
So who's guarding the camp?
We'll visit Forestlands capital and have a look around for ourselves.
Yay!
I wanna try coconut milk!
You can, son.
As much as you want.
How will they be able to go to the capital since they showed their faces?
I assume since they showed their faces, they know what they look like now.
Okay.
Bike time.
Yay!
Oh, sorry.
The team of four.
Sorry, you're right.
Now that there's a team of four, everything will be okay.
Can I fast travel here?
That fast travel here, does that work?
Oh, yeah, it does.
Okay, nice.
Here we go.
This way.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, I am.
Yay!
I still can't believe it.
I spent all that time upgrading my stuff and then they're like, you gotta use your arms.
I'm like, what the fuck?
You mean I gotta use my arms?
What's the point?
Probably that.
Uh.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
Fuck it, I need materials.
I need to test my new weapon.
Holy shit, two thousand!
Okay.
All right.
That was.
That was strong.
Two thousand.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
I just got my cherry blush!
I'm so happy to have it and want to let you know thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you Steven!
I'm so happy it arrived!
I'm really happy!
Uh, this way.
Where is it?
I think I have to go up.
What the fuck was that damage?
That's what we've waited for.
Wait, is it?
Are we supposed to head to Trigyn?
Wait, why do I have... Oh, I can't fast travel there.
I was like wondering...
Okay, I almost ran over.
I almost did it.
Yeah!
In Sand Land I could!
It's not fair!
You know what?
I need materials.
Get over here.
I need materials right now.
That's cute!
Oh, that's cute that you think you could survive that.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Oh, there might be... materials here too.
Who's in here?
Oh, scorpions!
Okay, this is my level 8 bike right now.
You can tell it's level 8.
Oh, I already was here.
Did I get anything?
Uh, I get an assassin, scorpion... Okay, you know what?
I might need that later.
I might need that.
We need to go back to Desert Land and we want to upgrade our bike though.
We don't have... Wait, there's a bridge here?
Bridge?
There we go.
Oooh, how do I get over there?
How do I get over there?
Nooo!
Oh, that's how.
Okay, nice.
I didn't realize there was a little area here.
You know what?
Fuck it.
This guy looked at me wrong.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, that is actually overkill.
Oh my god.
That is actually overkill.
My tank is so OP now.
Alright.
We're almost there.
We're almost back to the tank.
Not tank, to the camp.
Okay.
Alright, that's awkward.
That's really awkward.
We're just there.
At least it wasn't a game over screen.
General E.P.
Oh, there he is!
I was like, where's General E.P.?
He's at the top!
If it isn't the fickle macho with bumbling fiend himself.
I'm a...
May you get hangnails on all your fingers and toes.
What the fuck?
Don't worry, guys.
I just upgraded my tank.
That's fucking right.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, guys.
Wait, they're jumping above.
Guys.
They're jumping over my...
That wasn't part of the plan.
Okay, that was very smart when they jumped over my...
They're jumping over my...
They jumped over it.
You're the only one left, Eppy.
Yeah, surrender!
Before you dishonor yourself further.
Surrender?
No, no.
It doesn't end like this.
I'll be back with ten times the troops.
So wait here, trembling in fear.
Gary, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
It's a little too late.
Get on the bike, Beelzebub.
He's literally just running!
Bro!
Wait, but Lucifer, you need to go down.
Give me a sec, I'll...
Okay, okay now he's just running with his two feet How is he faster?
How is he 200 meters away from me already?
Was he 200 meters away
We're surrounded an ambush He's a very good runner
Oh, you're gonna regret that BAM!
That's right, and I have another take two Boom!
What a hit!
Okay, that shield has to be the strongest shield of existence That one guy survived a fucking missile Like what the fuck?
I'm just gonna run you over You know what?
I'm angry I'm gonna slowly run you over There you go Wait, you're still alive?
That's fucking right, that's right, you see me, I'm gonna come up That's fucking right
Oh I'm coming I've been waiting for you Okay,
well, I'm almost there Yeah, that's right I'll give you a chance Oh, I knew it I'm gonna have to go back and save you Go ahead Oh, no, do not I'm gonna have to go back and save you Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no The shield is strong No, no, no, no, no, no Yeah,
the shield is stronger than the tank plates It should have just made the tanks build off of those shields There is nothing I hate more in the entire world We're being told what to do Damn Damn!
What are you, fucking 12?
Duck, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I think that might be a war crime joke.
He started it!
I feel like a lot of wars...
That is like... almost like... that is like a war argument.
He started it.
Alright, there you go.
Nice, alright.
Fight time!
Look, it was self-defense!
Is this the camp?
Or no?
No.
Wait, I gotta destroy these guys.
I'm gonna punch a raptor.
Get over here.
Sorry.
I'll leave you.
I'll let you live.
I'll let him live.
Yeah, we're gonna go now!
Another trap!
How does he still have stuff?
What?
There's nobody here.
Is he just gonna walk away?
Bro!
He has no more reinforcements!
Oh, shut up!
And bring it so we can beat you down already!
You impertinent little brat!
He just walks away.
Wait.
Where is he going?
What?
He has his own mecha?
Where did he hide that?
That's fucking right.
This is what my tank is for!
The moment I hit it...
Okay.
This is a little awkward.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh shit!
Oops.
I forgot my HP, guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Take one!
This is okay.
This is why I got like 20 repair kits, guys.
It's okay.
I spent...
This is it.
It's okay.
We're fine now.
Now we're okay.
It's okay.
We're okay now.
Boost jump?
Where am I getting ahead to?
Oh shit!
The sky shot!
Look at that.
Oh!
But look at that damage though!
Look at that!
Look at that damage though!
Oh shit.
When I hit the shots though!
Look at the damage when the shots actually hit though!
Oh no.
Oh, they're like a lot slower.
Thank God.
Okay.
At least they are a lot slower though.
I appreciate that.
Guys, why didn't you tell me to upgrade sooner?
Haha!
Alright.
Well, this has to be the easiest fight ever.
I'm just gonna stand still.
YAY!
Hahaha!
Why didn't you listen?
Because I'm streaming.
Hahaha!
You have to tell me 80 times until I see it.
Oh.
We did it!
Yeah,
where's King Jam?
What are we gonna do?
The TV?
Yeah.
What does he mean by that?
Wait, what?
What is... what?
He has a necklace!
They used their mole to make it.
Curse you, bread.
So they went ahead with the coronation, even after our attack.
What quote unquote attack?
Look at what's on Mooniel's chest.
It's my necklace!
It could be a fake.
I doubt it would be that hard for them to get their hands on a decent forgery.
No.
Look at the square.
You can't see any of the damage from Guppy's attack.
My guess would be that they filmed all this beforehand.
Oh, damn.
That's smart.
When did this happen?
For I am the protector of this country!
Are you watching, dear citizens?
There has been a heinous attack on the coronation.
The despicable resistance has joined with Sandland's royal army.
Yeah, who was recording that?
Those were some good shots.
Who the fuck was recording that?
There was no cameraman.
All to prevent Mooniel from ascending to the throne.
Thankfully, we managed to foil their evil plot.
But this affront will not go unpunished.
Oh, so like, why is this like one screenshot FPS splicing right there?
I'm afraid that our brave soldiers and I managed to band together and try to outweigh this battle.
Wait, this was pre-recorded!
They realized this was gonna happen before the attack was coming.
I'm afraid that many of our countrymen gave their lives in the battle.
This was an unprovoked attack by Sandland!
Yeah, they planned all of this.
They filmed all of this in advance.
Like, even that part.
As your camp, I cannot give them the chance to commit further atrocities!
For the sake of those lives lost.
For our great patriots.
It is for them that I hereby declare war against Sandland!
Oh my god, no!
They have nothing!
They clearly just got water!
I
hate to admit it, but it looks like we've been had.
Oh.
It's over.
The forest land army is nearing the border as we speak.
What?
We've gotta let General Array know right now.
But we can't contact him unless we go back to Sandland.
No!
What are we waiting for?
I only get to be in forest land for one stream?
What do you mean I have to go back to Sandland?
I'm waiting for you.
I won't let them get hurt.
I'm sure your father would say the same thing.
Back to the sand.
To Sandland 2.
No more forest land.
Okay.
I literally just... I only got to experience forest land for one stream!
That is so fucked up!
What's up?
I'm so scared!
Holy shit!
How do I get back to Sandland?
Oh my god.
I'll just fast travel.
This is Rao.
General Array.
Back to Sandland I go.
This is Array.
I have urgent news from forest land.
Can we meet?
If this is about the declaration of war, I'm well aware.
We're busy preparing, so I'm stuck in the royal capital.
Understood.
And we'll head to the capital ourselves.
Much appreciated.
Until then, over and out.
Alright.
I think... I think this is a good time to call it.
I think... this is a good time... this is a good time to call it.
We left forest land and now we're back in Sandland.
I can't believe it, guys.
I can't...
We did all of that and now we're back to Sand...
It's like... we're back in Sand...
Stop it!
I only got to experience it for one stream!
How can they do this to me?
I just wanted to enjoy Sandland!
I want to enjoy forest land!
Cannot escape the Sand...
Alright.
I wonder if like...
Okay, I'm gonna check real fast.
Sand... land... no commentary.
I'm gonna check how much we actually have off of Sandland.
Because I feel like we're almost... we're close to it.
I think we are close to the ending.
Alright.
Where's the sand part?
Wait, we're actually pretty close!
Wait, is this it?
Yeah.
We have...
Technically four more hours.
Four more hours on...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I played like two hours...
Okay, alright.
Yeah, I think next week would be the last...
Next week would be the last section...
Of the... the Sandland.
I'm pretty sure.
Because there's like...
Four more hours left...
Wait, actually no.
13, 14, 15, 16, 17...
Four more hours left?
So that's just like...
I can enjoy this the next week.
Oh my god.
Next week would be the last final part of Sandland!
We'll have no more sand!
This has to be...
Definitely...
The...
The longest game...
Well, no.
Because I played Demon's Souls.
So like that was the longest...
Demon's Souls and Bloodborne.
That was the longest games I've ever played.
But like...
But yeah!
I mean it's been fun so far.
And then we get to...
We had a little fun time talking about...
At the start, talking about like...
Life updates and everything.
And...
Whoa!
I'm really tired.
But I always have a great time hanging out with you guys.
With you dragoons.
It always is a great time.
You know, to hang out with you guys.
And I hope you guys enjoyed...
Hope you guys enjoyed...
Sandland so far.
Next week would be the final part of Sandland.
So we have that left.
But also...
Regarding the tournament that's on Saturday.
Oh yeah.
I wrote in the community post.
For those who don't read the community post.
You're like...
Oh my god, Doki.
Why are you joining a tournament right before...
Your new skinsuit reveal?
Well, it's because...
RPR invited me to it.
And then I said like...
Oh yeah.
I didn't say why.
Because I didn't reveal my...
The skinsuit stuff yet.
So then I told him like...
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
Because 5pm is my...
It's a special stream that I have to do.
At 5pm.
So then he was like...
Alright, let me ask the organizer.
And then the organizer contacted me.
Because I think like...
The organizer wanted me as a captain.
For his tournament.
So like...
He contacted me about it.
And then I was just like...
Oh yeah.
Like RPR...
Like told me...
Yeah.
I was like...
RPR told me and...
Um...
Like I'm gonna be on his team.
And...
But then I was like...
Yeah...
Um...
I don't know if I can do it.
Because like...
It's on the same day as my skinsuit reveal.
Uh...
And then...
So then he was like...
I'll change the time of the tournament.
Like...
Is this time better?
I was like...
Oh I won't...
I don't want it like after...
I don't really want it after my skinsuit reveal.
Because I don't want to feel rushed.
To do a skinsuit reveal.
And he's like...
Okay.
I'll do it before your reveal.
Like...
Is this time better?
And then I felt bad.
Because like...
He was like...
I'm changing...
Like he was changing the time.
So...
So I was just like...
Okay.
I'll join.
Because they were...
Because like...
They were willing to change the time for it like two times.
So...
So they were like...
Okay.
So then that's why I said yes.
Because...
Uh...
They changed the time of the tournament for me.
Even though it's literally like...
Yesterday.
Literally yesterday.
Because I was like...
I don't know.
I have to...
They changed it yesterday.
Because I was like...
It's not like they changed the time for me.
So I felt like...
It was so last minute of a change.
Yeah.
They're working around my schedule.
So I was like...
Yeah.
I can do it.
As long as...
As long as it's before the reveal.
It's fine.
So apparently...
We don't know who...
Apparently it's like a new third-person shooter game.
With like...
Anime waifus.
And...
The betas coming...
It's like a beta launch tournament or something.
So I don't know who else is invited.
But RPR told me...
At the moment my team is...
So, it's me, RPR, Surefour, and RaffleGator.
We don't know who our fifth is because he's still looking for a fifth at the moment.
He was like, I'm gonna be recruiting a team that's gonna win it all!
Which I don't know.
I don't know who else is participating.
But like...
I mean, Surefour's playing on it.
So like... and he's like a natural gifted aimer.
So...
So, if anything fails, we have Surefour.
But yeah!
I don't know who our fifth is.
I just found out who our four other players are.
But yeah!
Anyway, I have a lot of work to do today!
So, I am going to call it here, everybody.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Where's my... Oh, there it is!
I was like, where's the screen for... where's the scene for this?
Bye for real!
Bye!